bien Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues la commission d'enquête
chargée d'établir les raisons de la
perte de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France poursuit
aujourd'hui c'est cette semaine ces
travaux avec plusieurs auditions nous
commençons cette après-midi par
l'audition de Madame Ségolène Royal
madame la ministre nous vous remercions
d'avoir accepté d'être auditionné par
notre commission d'enquête au titre de
diverses fonctions que vous avez
exercées notamment la fonction
ministérielle
dédiée à l'énergie entre 2014 et 2017
qui intéresse plus particulièrement nos
travaux l'un des présidents d'honneur
d'EDF entendu par notre commission avait
observé pour la période antérieure à ses
fonctions que les candidats au deuxième
tour des élections présidentielles de
2007 ne s'était guère affronté sur le
thème de l'énergie lequel semblait faire
alors consensus
c'est quelque chose qui a peut-être été
contredit par une audition
ultérieure d'ailleurs selon le décret
relatif à vos attributions
ministérielles pour la période 2014 2017
vous étiez chargé au titre de l'énergie
du climat d'élaborer et de mettre en
œuvre la politique de l'énergie je cite
afin notamment d'assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique et de
promouvoir la transition énergétique fin
de citation
conjointement avec le ministre de
l'économie du redressement productif et
du numérique que nous auditionnerons
prochainement vous étiez également
compétente pour je cite à nouveau la
politique des matières premières et des
mines en ce qui concerne les matières
énergétiques fin de citation
la commission d'enquête a précédemment
auditionné Monsieur Antoine Peillon qui
fut votre conseiller technique énergie
et Monsieur Manuel Valls qui dirigeait
le gouvernement auquel vous apparteniez
alors la loi relative à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte du
17 août 2015
occupe une place très importante dans
les travaux de notre commission elle a
été abondamment citée je rappelle que
cette loi a institué les programmations
pluriannuelles de l'énergie et les
stratégies nationales bas carbone
peut-être aujourd'hui de le dire dans
l'autre sens d'ailleurs
cette loi comportait de nombreuses
dispositions en matière d'économie
d'énergie tant dans le bâtiment que dans
les transports elle prévoyait un
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
elle prescrivait aussi de fermer les
centrales à charbon d'ici 2023 de
plafonner la capacité des installations
nucléaires à 63,2 gigawatts et de
réduire à l'horizon 2025 la part de la
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire puisque 50% de la production
d'électricité devait être à cet échéance
réservée aux énergies renouvelables
EDF n'était pas alors confronté au
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
que nous connaissons cet hiver mais ces
documents de référence annuel décrivent
les risques auxquels le groupe devait
faire face en particulier les règles de
concurrence les politiques publiques et
les exigences de la sûreté des systèmes
électriques interconnés interconnecté
dans celui de 2016 au sujet du
plafonnement à 63,2 gigawatts ce rapport
évoque les décisions d'arrêt prématuré
d'une ou plusieurs tranches du parc ne
résulte pas d'un choix industriel mais
d'une application de la loi
nous n'oublions pas par ailleurs que
votre nom est associé à la cop21 la
France ayant souhaité se montrer
exemplaire dans ce domaine et devenir le
fer de lance de cette nouvelle cause en
faveur de l'humanité
voilà madame la ministre après ces
quelques mots d'introduction il me
revient de vous demander et avant de
vous laisser la parole de bien vouloir
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité et rien que la vérité en vertu
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 je vous prie donc de bien
vouloir lever la main droite et lire je
le jure madame la ministre je vous
laisse la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mais
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
je propose de vous dire quelques mots
sur la loi du 17 août 2015 même si vous
venez d'en dire déjà beaucoup et puis
ensuite de répondre de répondre le plus
rapidement possible à vos questions
alors pourquoi cette loi de doute de
2015 parce que en effet la France avait
voulu devant recevoir la COP 21 mois de
décembre qui suivait le mois d'août 2015
la conférence donc de Paris sur le
climat moi j'étais chef de délégation
donc en tant que ministre de
l'environnement et de l'énergie c'est
leur vue ce qui présidait la
mais moi j'avais la responsabilité de
l'avancée dans le domaine de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique de
façon opérationnelle et j'avais voulu
vraiment que la France puisse finaliser
sa stratégie bas carbone pour être
exemplaire en arrivant à la cop21 et
d'ailleurs nous avons été l'un des
premiers pays du monde à faire adopter
par le Parlement une stratégie bas
carbone de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique le souci qui était le bien
c'était pas seulement de faire voter une
loi mais aussi d'en prendre les décrets
d'application pendant le débat
parlementaire ayant siéger pendant 20
ans sur vos bancs pendant quatre mandats
je sais à quel point j'ai vu tellement
de ministres et de trop content de faire
voter des lois sans se préoccuper des
textes d'application ni des mesures
opérationnelles qui vont avec que mon
souci a été à la fois donc de faire
adopter cette loi de façon la plus
consensuelle possible on y reviendra
sans doute ensuite de prévoir les textes
d'application et surtout de mettre en
place les partie opérationnel des
politiques nécessaires à cette
transition énergétique je vais y revenir
aussi dans quelques instants notamment
en vous disant quelques mots sur la
finance verte
cette loi je lui avais assigné trois
objectifs pour la première fois il y
avait le mot d'ailleurs de croissance
verte dans un texte législatif donc
premièrement lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique puisque nous
étions avant la cop21 ensuite réduire la
facture énergétique était à ce moment là
de 70 milliards de déficits dans la
balance commerciale et troisièmement de
faire de notre pays un champion dans le
domaine industriel et d'innovation sur
tous les secteur clé de l'industrie et
énergétique et de l'efficacité
énergétique et puis enfin c'est de
donner aussi au territoire et aux
citoyens les moyens de participer à
cette transition et notamment avec la
création des des têtes CV des
territoires énergies positifs pour la
croissance verte
et puis mon souci aussi c'était de au
moment où je voyais monter la
compétition mondiale sur notamment les
énergies renouvelables et sur
l'efficacité énergétique des bâtiments
et sur le transport propre c'est de
faire en sorte que on utilise la COP 21
pour aussi pousser nos industriels à
être très en avant sur tous ces secteurs
la performance énergétique portée sur
les bâtiments et transports l'économie
circulaire je vais aller vite les EnR
les énergies renouvelables la France et
ses outre-mer en tout le soleil les
énergies marines les éoliennes la
géothermie l'hydrolien le bois on a tout
en France par rapport à tous les les
sources d'énergie renouvelables et
notamment une des la première puissance
maritime du monde donc avec les énergies
marines ont toujours constitué pour moi
aussi une opportunité très forte
alors qu'elles étaient les trois
objectifs politiques de cette loi
d'abord et je dirais je l'aurais répété
pendant tout le débat parlementaire
c'était de ne pas opposer les énergies
les unes aux autres
deuxièmement c'était de faire en sorte
que nous soyons un pays qui n'est ni
pénurie ni dépendances donc ça ça
rejoint à votre préoccupation et
troisièmement je cite encore le la loi
l'exposé des motifs de la loi c'est de
réaliser un champ d'énergie propre sur
et les moins chers possibles propres sur
et les moins chers possibles
et ce qui m'avait inspiré ce que j'ai
redis dans l'exposé des motifs de cette
loi c'est que la France a toujours
fait preuve d'un grand volontarisme en
termes de politique énergétique pas
seulement d'ailleurs ressortir de la
guerre avec la Communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier qui font qui a
posé les fondements de l'Europe mais
aussi quand on regarde les travaux du
Conseil National de la Résistance on
voit que déjà l'énergie est présentée
comme le levier majeur de développement
ce qui a conduit d'ailleurs au
développement du service public de
l'énergie en même temps que la sécurité
sociale vous voyez le Conseil National
de la Résistance a créhaustive service
public de l'énergie et c'est à partir de
là que la France a fait le choix de
créer des entreprises publiques
puissantes et en particulier
l'édification des barrages dont on parle
pas suffisamment mais quand on regarde
les films de l'époque sur la
construction des barrages c'est juste
éblouissant les ouvriers les ingénieurs
sont des quand même extra extraordinaire
j'y reviendrai parce que j'ai aussi
soucis de défendre les barrages
lorsqu'il y a eu les remises en
concurrence des concessions et je vous
expliquerai comment donc il y a eu des
investissements massifs dans l'énergie
et au fond en 2015 que je dis au
Parlement c'est que nous devons faire le
même effort
d'imagination d'investissement
d'anticipation du futur par rapport à ce
tournant que nous devons prendre sur
l'autonomie énergétique et sur la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique tu es
venu le choc pétrolier de 73 avec la
multiplication par 4 du prix du brut et
d'où le programme nucléaire qui s'est
accéléré lancé par la France qui était
absolument unique au monde avec plus
d'une quarantaine de réacteurs
construits en 10 ans et là aussi c'était
la traduction d'un très fort
volontarisme politique
donc comment pouvons-nous continuer à
être les meilleurs dans le domaine de
l'énergie
alors premièrement économiser l'énergie
ça c'était le grand chantier du bâtiment
pour créer des emplois et faire baisser
les factures puisque le bâtiment on le
redira jamais assez et le premier
secteur consommateur en énergie avant
les transports et l'industrie d'où
l'importance vraiment des travaux de
rénovation d'isolation les nouveaux
bâtiments énergies positives les réseaux
intelligents et les territoires énergies
positifs comme j'expliquais tout à
l'heure pour que les collectivités
locales est absolument les moyens de
réaliser l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments notamment des bâtiments
publics
deuxième pilier après cette performance
énergétique c'est les énergies
renouvelables
je rappelle que la France et le premier
potentiel agricole européen dont tous
les débouchés sur la méthanisation sur
les sur les biocarburants deuxièmement
nous avons le troisième potentiel
forestier nous sommes la première
puissance maritime je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure avec les outre-mer nous sommes
le premier producteur européen d'énergie
renouvelable avec l'hydroélectricité qui
a donc réglé le problème de stockage de
l'énergie et cette loi donc pose comme
objectif 32% d'énergie renouvelable en
2030 contre 14% en 2012 et par
conséquent se fixer effectivement des
objectifs ambitieux
dans le Titre 1 les objectifs sont très
clairement mis exprimées pour renforcer
l'indépendance énergétique pour lutter
contre les catastrophes climatiques avec
les grands chiffres que vous avez
rappelé le nucléaire à 50% à l'horizon
2025 la réduction de 40 % en 2030 des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport à l'année 1990 qu'on a appelé le
facteur 4 alors c'est tout le jargon
chaque fois il fallait expliquer
pourquoi facteur 4 parce que c'est
divisé par 4 depuis 1990 le facteur 4
ensuite la réduction de moitié de la
consommation d'énergie à l'horizon 2050
par rapport à 2012
en portant le rythme annuel de baisse de
l'intensité énergétique de deux et demi
pour cent tous les ans d'ici 2030 ça
c'est très important parce que ça paraît
petit de virgule 5%, mais c'est très
important et un pilotage doit voir ce
qui se passe année après année pas
attendre tranquillement 2030 pour dire
tiens au fait où on en est mais être
capable de mesurer année après année et
puis de rectifier le tir si jamais on
n'avait pas les deux et demi pour cent
de la baisse du rythme manuel de
l'intensité énergétique et enfin 32%
d'énergie renouvelable comme vous le
savez dans la consommation énergétique
finale en 2030 mais ce qui était très
important aussi de préciser parce que
comment est-ce qu'on y arrive on y
arrive en portant la part de la chaleur
renouvelable à 38%, qu'est-ce que c'est
la chaleur renouvelable c'est la
biomasse
par le bois la valorisation des déchets
la géothermie et monsieur le Président
vous savez peut-être vous n'étiez pas
encore élu à ce moment là mais j'ai eu
le plaisir d'inaugurer en Alsace deux
champions de réalisation industrielle
exceptionnelle dans ce domaine à la fois
la géothermie profonde qui était une
première mondiale avec le pompage de
l'eau à 2500 mètres de profondeur et
puis un équipement de bio de
valorisation de biomasse bois aussi en
Alsace donc deux éléments clés que je
suis allé visiter tout en allant a fait
ce nime nous y reviendrons montrer aussi
qu'il y avait une diversité des
territoires et puis en portant la part
des biocarburants à 15%. donc voilà les
grands traits de la loi de transition
énergétique les objectifs à la fois
opérationnels qui avaient aussi vocation
à tri ajustée au fur et à mesure parce
que bien évidemment quand on projette
des choses à 2030 il y avait cette
possibilité de ajuster au fur et à
mesure grâce à la programmation plus
manuelle de l'énergie c'est-à-dire pour
la première fois je crée dans cette loi
un outil qui permet non pas de tâtonner
année après année mais de de
programmer des stratégies énergétiques
avec la capacité de les réactualiser au
fur et à mesure
et pour terminer donc je voudrais aussi
préciser que
mon souci a été de mettre en place les
outils d'accompagnement de cette loi et
en particulier la finance verte pourquoi
la finance verte parce que je me suis
rendu compte après avoir vécu les
chèques de Copenhague m'était rendu en
tant que président de région avec les
collectivités territoriales que nous
n'arriverions à
faire l'accord de Paris sur le climat
que si le secteur financier basculait du
côté de du financement des stratégies
baccarbones et quant au mois de juillet
il y a eu pour la première fois la
coalition finance verte qui s'est réunie
à Paris où on l'a vu les banques et les
assurances commencer à basculer du côté
de la nécessité de la finance verte
pourquoi tout simplement parce que les
assurances n'arrivaient plus à assurer
les dégâts climatiques donc à un moment
elles se sont dit mais il faut qu'on
investisse aussi dans les stratégies de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
parce que c'est notre intérêt
et donc il est une convergence vertueuse
des intérêts tant mieux et à ce moment
là j'ai eu soucis puisque je présidais
la coalition finance verte donc je suis
allé à Washington lors de la réunion de
des grands financeurs de la du Fond
Monétaire International de la Banque
mondiale avec le secrétaire général des
Nations unies qui étaient bannes Kimon à
ce moment-là et c'est pour ça que
j'avais été soucieuse que la France soit
à l'avant-garde des sujets finance verte
on a donc adopté un prix du carbone un
des tout premier pays du monde à le
faire
j'ai créé par l'article 163 de la loi de
transition énergétique et l'intégration
du risque climatique dans le reporting
de la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises des investisseurs on a eu
d'ailleurs des fonds d'investissement
français qui ont pu se développer grâce
à ça et ensuite cet article 173 a servi
d'ailleurs de référence à la finance
verte mondiale puisque d'autres pays
l'ont adopté nous avons créé un label
transition énergétique pour le climat
avec des fonds labellisés pour un
encours de 1,2,5 milliards d'euros et un
label financement participatif pour la
croissance verte et surtout nous avons
mis sur le marché en janvier 2017
les premiers green bandes la première
obligation verte souveraine donc je
réunis toutes les banques et les
assurances et les fonds d'investissement
avec France Trésor et nous avons réussi
à mettre ça sur le marché pour 7
milliards d'euros c'est à dire alors que
ce qui nous en cours demandé a été même
supérieur à ce que nous avons sur le
marché donc l'État a mis 7 milliards
d'euros sur le marché et nous avions une
demande du secteur bancaire du secteur
financier je m'en souviens fort bien
parce que ça nous avait même étonné de
11 milliards d'euros donc on a eu 200
investisseurs sur le cette obligation
verte souveraine et l'idée c'était de
financer des politiques avec ces
investissements en faveur de
l'environnement et de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
parallèlement toujours sur la finance
verte nous avons mis en place un fonds
de financement de la transition
énergétique de 250 millions d'euros mis
en place des prêts pour la croissance
verte géré par la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation pour 3 milliards de d'euros
mise en place des nouvelles règles
créant des marchés et réduisant les
coûts mise en place des soutiens aux
particuliers avec le crédit le
doublement du crédit d'impôt transition
énergétique la réforme des prêts à taux
zéro et le cumul possible entre le
crédit d'impôt et les prêts à taux zéro
mis en place des sociétés de tiers
financement pour faire l'avance des
fonds aux particuliers et enfin
faciliter l'émergence de projets urbains
innovant exemplaires avec des
démonstrateurs industriels pour la ville
durable et également le lancement des
projets de transport propre avec la
multiplication en fait d'appels à
projets qui ont permis d'accélérer la
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables pour densité que
quelques-uns les lancements
d'accélération des appels à projets sur
l'éolien en mer avec Dunkerque l'île
d'Oléron Noirmoutier qui ont été d'un
quartier récemment inauguré d'ailleurs
le lancement des appels à projets sur
l'éolien flottant sur la méthanisation
sur la biomasse sur les réseaux de
chaleur bref l'État a été
locomotive avec ce système des appels à
projets pour mobiliser les investisseurs
et surtout leur donner de la sécurité et
je terminerai par là je pense que dans
le domaine de la transition énergétique
il faut de la stabilité et de la
sécurité et effectivement l'un des
grands regrets pas pour moi et pour la
France c'est que au changement
ministériel comme vous le savez beaucoup
de choses se sont effondrées beaucoup de
recul ont été malheureusement actées et
les principales victimes finalement de
ces reculs ce sont les entreprises ce
sont les industriels parce que vous
voyez elles ont besoin de stabilité
elles ont besoin d'arrêter des
stratégies elles ont besoin de
durabilité dans le domaine de leur
vision économique et de leur business
model et quand ça bouge tout le temps et
ben c'est impossible d'investir donc
voilà si c'est surtout qui contient un
travail qui est fait de façon le plus la
plus consensuelle possible je pense que
l'intérêt énergétique de la France c'est
son intérêt énergétique et je pense que
l'idéologie ce que j'imagine que vos
questions vont porter là-dessus pro ou
anti-nucléaire n'a aucun sens on n'est
pas pro ou anti-nucléaire on est pour un
modèle énergétique équilibré ou pour
l'énergie la moins chère qui nous donne
la meilleure indépendance et avec une
stabilité des règles qui permet à cette
énergie qui la vie
l'énergie c'est ce qui est plus
important dans un pays dans une
stratégie c'est la vie tout simplement
et d'ailleurs on voit que les pays qui
en sont privés n'arrivent pas à se
développer je pense en particulier à
tout le continent africain il y a encore
des centaines de millions de gens qui
ont pas accès à l'énergie et ça c'est un
véritable problème qui est d'ailleurs
été aussi évoqué à la COP 21
merci Madame la Ministre d'abord je vous
rassurez en 2015 lorsque vous étiez dans
le Haut-Rhin ou en 2016 lorsque vous
êtes allé visiter la géothermie à
ritershofen j'étais bien élu locale et
j'étais bien attentif déjà au sujet
énergétique
j'aurai une première question qui qui va
au-delà de la période pendant laquelle
vous vous étiez en responsabilité
ministérielle simplement pour
contextualiser un petit peu parce qu'on
a eu je crois deux informations un peu
contradictoires dans les auditions que
nous avons déjà pu faire
je l'ai abordé dans mon propos
introductif sur le l'ambiance sur la
question énergétique à l'occasion de la
campagne présidentielle de 2007 est-ce
que dans vos souvenirs l'énergie était
ou non un sujet de campagne de clivage
ou finalement c'était un non sujet dans
le paysage politique de l'époque
de mémoire c'était pas un sujet archi
prioritaire
d'accord plutôt raison
dirigeant d'EDF qui nous a répondu sur
cette question là on nous a
on nous a beaucoup parlé du changement
de paradigme
dans la vision que enfin beaucoup
certains
dans la vision de la stratégie
énergétique a constitué la COP 21
en passant donc du Facteur 4 au 0
émission nette
j'ai beaucoup de mal enfin vous avez
fait un propos liminaire dans lequel
vous avez longuement expliqué à quel
point anticiper était nécessaire et
important à la matière et du coup j'ai
beaucoup de mal à comprendre en quoi la
Coop même si au niveau international y
compris français elle change et elle
durci un peu les objectifs en quoi elle
correspond en un tournant ou on a un
tournoi aussi brusque en matière de
stratégie énergétique
la coque constituée un tournant brusque
parce que pour la première fois
l'ensemble des pays du monde en signant
un traité reconnaissent que ce sont les
activités humaines et le recours aux
énergies fossiles qui sont à l'origine
du déréglement climatique fait moi j'ai
vécu des gens en tant que mise de
l'environnement en 1992 le premier
sommet de la planète à Rio François
Mitterrand et pendant ce premier sommet
de la planète où déjà beaucoup de choses
ont été dites quand on regarde les
différents discours politiques on se
connaissait déjà le réchauffement
climatique mais à ce moment là il y
avait les climato-sceptiques dont
certains de grands scientifiques qui
signaient des pétitions pour dire que
c'était une illusion que de penser que
le réchauffement climatique était dû à
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles et
donc c'est pour c'est ça que tout d'un
coup enfin tout d'un coup non au bout
d'un long processus puisque au 21 ça
veut dire quand même qu'il y a eu au
moins 21 21 COP il a fallu attendre 21
cops c'est à dire 25 25 ans puisque
certaines années il y a pas eu de Coop
pour qu'enfin les pays reconnaissent là
et la seconde chose c'est que tous les
pays se sont engagés à faire leur
stratégie bas carbone c'était très
nouveau ça les pays pauvres comme les
pays riches d'ailleurs et troisièmement
le troisième pilier de la de la cop21
c'était la finance le financement donc
il y a le traité il y a les stratégies
bas carbone national obligatoire il y a
la finance et puis le dernier élément
dont j'avais la responsabilité pendant
la COP 21 c'était l'agenda de l'action
et c'était très innovant l'agenda de
l'action c'est d'ailleurs été
passionnant puisque dans cet agenda de
l'action on avait 70 coalitions qui
couvrait tous les secteurs de l'activité
économique le bâtiment les transports la
forêt l'eau la mer etc et pour la
première fois j'ai fait inscrire dans
les dans les discussions et dans
l'accord de Paris sur le climat deux
éléments nouveaux l'océan
qui n'existait pas pendant les
précédentes cops ce qui est quand même
étonnant parce que c'est quand même 70%
de la surface de la planète mais l'océan
n'existait pas pourquoi parce qu'il y a
pas de chef d'État de l'océan donc les
négociations diplomatiques avaient
éliminé ces facteurs clés à la fois de
plus de carbone de potentiels des
énergies renouvelables de problématiques
sur la biodiversité avec la surpêche par
exemple et on a fait rentrer l'océan
dans les négociations de biodiversité et
de stratégies climat d'une part et le
deuxième élément nouveau qui a été
introduit dans le traité de la cop21
c'est ce sont les femmes
ce sont les femmes avec
le fait que les femmes sont les
premières victimes du dérèglement
climatique quand il y a des catastrophes
climatiques il y a beaucoup plus de
femmes victimes pourquoi parce qu'elles
ont le emploient leurs enfants les
employaient les personnes âgées elles
savent pas nager elles savent pas monter
aux armes et j'avais réuni pendant la
cop21 une association une grande réunion
de femmes où il y a eu aussi peut-être
600 ou 700 femmes de tous les pays du
monde et ce que les femmes nous ont
demandé c'est de leur apprendre à nager
et à monter aux armes c'est-à-dire les
éléments de survie physique qu'elle
n'avait pas et deuxièmement ce qui est
reconnu dans cette cop21 c'est que les
femmes ont des solutions ou des
règlements climatiques d'abord parce que
ce sont elles qui lancent l'alerte se
sont elles qui ont vu que il y avait
moins en moins d'eau qu'il fallait faire
de plus en plus de kilomètres en Afrique
pour aller chercher le bois etc donc
elles avaient alerté depuis très
longtemps sur le dérèglement climatique
et d'ailleurs les grands les grandes
militantes de environnement des femmes
au départ sont des femmes que ce soit
Rachel Carlson que ce soit
wengariat j'avais invité à la COP 21 où
les femmes se révoltent par exemple
contre la déforestation parce que ce
sont elles qui sont
90% des agriculteurs sont des
agriculteurrices à travers le monde donc
l'impact de la pauvrissement du
dérèglement climatique ce sont les
femmes qui le subissent
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments j'en
reviens peut-être plus précisément aux
questions énergétiques du coup
une des personnes que nous avons
proposons libre tant qu'ils sont exacts
la question énergétique une des
personnes que nous avons auditionné
nous a expliqué en quelque sorte qui a
été en responsabilité de façon
contemporaine à l'exercice de fonction
ministérielle que sur le plan la
stratégie énergétique nationale et
notamment la mobilisation des
technologies
disponible et des scénarios la COP a
signé et
la prise en compte de la stratégie
zéro émission nette a signé un certain
nombre de changements de cap y compris
par moment de renoncement et de virages
à 180 degrés est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous fait écho ou pas
est-ce que vous pourriez préciser de
changement de cap en France vous voulez
dire oui en France
parce que nous on avait arrêté notre
stratégie avant la Coop parce que la loi
justement elle est adoptée avant la Coop
pour pour anticiper le contenu de
l'accord de Paris sur le climat donc on
a anticipé au contraire la
Coop elle a pas de d'impact très
opérationnel direct dans tel ou tel pays
elle fixe des grands objectifs elle
oblige chaque pays à faire sa stratégie
bas carbone et à ce moment-là il
appartient à chaque pays de d'obéir au
traité qu'il a signé et de mettre ses
politiques nationales en cohérence
c'est-à-dire essentiellement diminuant
les gaz à effet de serre
et quelle vision prospective vous avez à
cette époque là du de l'évolution du mix
énergétique et je parle bien énergétique
français à ce moment-là c'est plus
qu'une vision puisque j'ai fait voter
donc ce mix énergétique il est dans la
loi de transition énergétique ma vision
ça donne pas opposer les énergies les
unes aux autres ça c'est le premier
point on a besoin de toutes les énergies
il y a une complémentarité après il y a
les objectifs qui ont été fixés dans la
loi que j'ai redonné tout à l'heure
c'est bon il y a eu 50% de la baisse à
50% du de production nucléaire pour
l'électricité et puis ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure sur la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables et
sur la montée en puissance des économies
d'énergie
du coup comment est-ce que vous
construisez ce que vous conjuguez ça
avec ce que sont à l'époque les
scénarios de RTE notamment
et le et la définition du besoin futur
en électricité
il y a deux hypothèses il y a deux
hypothèses c'est à dire soit on est
capable
extrêmement performant et c'était le
choix qui avait été le mien dans les
économies d'énergie parce que les
économies d'énergie l'énergie qu'on ne
consomme pas c'est quand même la moins
chère et donc ma grande priorité ça
avait été les économies d'énergie d'où
le crédit d'impôt de transition
énergétique avait été facile à obtenir
dans les arbitrages interministériels
vous imaginez bien d'où les territoires
énergies positifs parce que je considère
et nous considérons et nous le savons
que 70% des travaux d'économie d'énergie
sont faits à une dimension
infra-nationale et donc que si on laisse
la liberté à toutes les collectivités
locales de définir la liste de tous les
bâtiments publics toutes les écoles
devraient être par exemple isolées les
écoles et lycées les collèges tout ça
devrait être isolés c'était l'objectif
des territoires énergies positifs et je
suis sûr qu'on y serait parvenu
aujourd'hui s'il n'avait pas été arrêté
après moi c'est évident parce que il y a
eu un
engagement des territoires dans la
transition énergétique
qui était vraiment magnifique puisque
même les mères qui étaient très
éloignées de ça qui n'avaient jamais
réfléchi à cette question là quand il se
saisissait des territoires énergies
positifs où je suis lancé 100% des
opérations pour bien le dire et ayant
été moi-même présidente de région je
connaissais parfaitement
qu'elles étaient les freins aux
innovations locales la galère des
cofinancements la galère des contrôles
techniques la galère de ceci la guerre
de cela donc j'avais dit on met en place
un fond confinement finance à 100%
on fait une un cadrage qui reprend les
grandes thématiques de la transition
énergétique et on laisse sa liberté
collectivité les territoriales de
définir quels bâtiment parce que il y a
une diversité il y a des endroits on
peut faire du soleil d'autres non des
endroits on peut faire d'éoliens
d'autres noms des endroits où il y a de
la forêt d'autres non donc ça n'a aucun
sens d'aller imposer des formats
uniformes et donc cette grande liberté
des collectivités territoriales
et moi même j'avais tout fait pour faire
de ma région une région d'excellence
environnementale donc j'avais un peu
d'expérience dans la réalisation des
choses puisque le premier lycée que
j'appelle lycée Kyoto du nom du
protocole de Kyoto à Poitiers lycée
professionnel en 2004 je lance un lycée
autonome en énergie et puis tout le
reste suit la méthanisation même la
voiture électrique en Poitou-Charentes à
partir de Liège tous les secteurs de la
transition énergétique avant même d'être
ministre je les lance dans mon
territoire régional donc forte de cette
expérience je vois qu'elles sont les
freins dans les différents territoires
et je leur donne les moyens de
développer leur projet
je reviens un peu sur la question du mix
énergétique parce que
je vais préciser du coup la question
c'est notamment l'audition à l'occasion
de l'audition de de François brodt qui
l'a souligné à quel point
finalement mais c'est du coup c'est
surprenant par rapport à l'ordre dans
lequel les choses se passent que vous
venez nous rappeler à quel point la Coop
a pu changer la vision qu'on avait du
besoin en matière d'électricité en
France et donc changer la stratégie de
production d'électricité à terme
je prends un exemple
elle avait dit vous faites le voter la
loi tpcv vous mettez en place les
crédits je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est une époque où j'étais élue locale
avec les têtes CV on a changé le
Berlingo de la commune pour acheter un
Berlingo électrique
ça constitue un transfert d'usage
énergétique on ne consomme les pas en
l'occurrence moins d'énergie mais une
énergie décarbonée
et pour autant les scénarios sur
lesquels
la loi tpcv est construite les scénarios
énergétiques et notamment sur les
besoins en matière d'électricité
continue de considérer à l'époque alors
même que le transfert d'usage est déjà
engagé
que nous aurons besoin de moins
d'électricité demain
je me replace en 2015 aujourd'hui il
semble que ces scénarios est appelé à
côté
quelle vision est-ce que vous en avez
mais je crois pas qu'elle loi disent
qu'on est moins d'énergie qu'on ait
besoin de moins d'énergie la loi dit il
faut faire un maximum de d'efforts pour
économiser l'énergie et en particulier
dans le bâtiment et dans dans la chaleur
notamment en passant par la biomasse et
la méthanisation etc deuxièmement la loi
ne donne pas les chiffres sur la
consommation précisément c'est pour ça
que je prévois une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie c'est pour
que avec les opérateurs économiques du
pays on puisse définir ensemble quels
sont les besoins en matière énergétique
mais donc les deux les deux hypothèses
sont ouvertes à ce moment-là et donc
soit on est capable de faire des
économies d'énergie et à ce moment-là la
croissance économique peut se poursuivre
mag avec moins de consommation d'énergie
parce qu'il y aura
un fort résultat
dans le domaine de l'économie d'énergie
et je rappelais tout à l'heure c'est le
bâtiment qui est le premier consommateur
d'énergie donc si vous faites un effort
considérable sur le bâtiment vous arrive
à diminuer la consommation d'énergie
c'est bien ça qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'on peut faire une révolution
une révolution énergétique si tous les
bâtiments en France sont isolés si tous
les nouveaux bâtiments comme je l'avais
prévu ça a été remise en cause
sont tous des bâtiments énergies
positifs c'est à dire qu'il produisent
plus d'énergie qu'il en consomme comme
il y a seulement quelques bâtiments mais
si cette norme avait été imposée à tous
les nouveaux bâtiments alors on aurait
réussi à diminuer la consommation non
seulement à diminuer la consommation
énergétique mais a constitué en France
des champions industriels les plus en
avance du monde entier puisque
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'oriente vers
les bâtiments économes en énergie et
donc le retard qui a été accumulé parce
que tout a été remis en cause notamment
vraiment le crédit d'impôt qui
permettait de créer des emplois et de
pousser les entreprises à se spécialiser
dans le secteur des économies d'énergie
et quand ça a été arrêté il y a eu 10
licenciements par exemple dans le
domaine de du doublage des vitres par
exemple ou d'isolation des combles donc
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que moi ma
conviction c'était que dans ce domaine
là les choses pouvaient aller très très
vite pouvait tirer l'industrie française
vers le haut vous pouvez tirer les
secteurs du bâtiment vers le haut et
pouvez permettre de de déboucher aussi
sur des innovations
technologiques importantes et notamment
le la gestion intelligente de la
consommation énergétique
justement quand vous parlez de tirer les
industries françaises vers le haut
comment comment vous vous envisagez ça à
l'époque puisque finalement il y a peu
d'industries françaises en matière
notamment d'énergie production d'énergie
vous avez pas mal parlé de des économies
d'énergie venant un peu à la question de
la production d'énergie tant en matière
d'éolien terrestre que de
photovoltaïques il y a
quasiment pas de filière industrielle ou
alors en difficulté qui qui ne sort pas
de leur difficulté dans cette période
comment est-ce que vous envisagez cette
question de la souveraineté industrielle
sur les sujets de production d'énergie
alors deux choses d'abord on est quand
même des leaders en matière d'énergie
renouvelable avec l'hydroélectricité
comme jamais oublier ça que on aurait eu
la capacité de développer l'hydrolien ce
que j'ai fait d'ailleurs en inaugurant
une ferme hydrolienne à Dunkerque on a
la capacité avec notre
notre domaine maritime on aurait eu la
capacité de développer les énergies
marines avec les appels à tous les
appels à projets que j'avais lancé qui
ont été arrêtés et de structurer des
vrais filières industrielles dans ce
domaine c'était l'objectif de tous les
appels à projets qui ont été lancés à ce
moment-là dans tous les domaines tous
les jours on s'attelait ils appellent à
projet l'augmentation des tarifs de
rachat de l'énergie la structuration des
filières les investissements d'avenir il
y a eu un effort assez considérable et
moi je
note je regardais ce qui se passait dans
les autres pays qu'est-ce que je voyais
je voyais en Espagne un fort
investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables d'ailleurs ils sont très
forts et ceux qui ont beaucoup de gagne
beaucoup d'appels à projets mondiaux je
voyais la Chine accélérée à la fois le
nucléaire mais ce qu'on oublie c'est que
la Chine se raccorder encore plus
rapidement que le nucléaire vers le
soleil
et vers l'éolien donc je voyais des
autres continents qui accélèrent cette
cette transition et je me disais que la
France avait les moyens
aussi d'investir on est toujours en
avance on a beaucoup inventé beaucoup de
choses j'avais en France donc il y a eu
une centrale nucléaire mais pendant le
nucléaire il y avait Font-Romeu
l'énergie solaire elle a été les
premières réalisations d'énergie solaire
c'est en France les premières
réalisations d'éoliennes ce sont des
laboratoires de Poitiers la première
voiture électrique c'est une Peugeot 205
c'est pour ça que j'avais relancé la
voiture électrique compris dans ma
région avec Liège les premiers bus
électrique c'est le liège
et pourtant c'était pas facile vous
savez quand j'ai invité le ministre de
l'Industrie dans ma région on va visiter
elienne et ben volontairement il fait un
détour pour ne pas aller voir la chaîne
de fabrication de la mia électrique en
disant que c'était pas une solution
d'avenir ça n'avait aucun sens etc donc
il faut il faut être un peu visionnaire
parfois aussi sur les sur les choses et
moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui il est
anormal qu'en Europe nous n'ayons pas de
grands fabricants de panneaux
photovoltaïques alors on dit que c'est
moins cher en Chine je veux dire
protégeons-nous puisqu'il y a le plus
qu'il y a le prix du carbone faire venir
un panneau solaire de Chine en terme de
de bilan carbone c'est bien supérieur
que si on le fabrique et d'ailleurs dans
ma région il y a eu un sous-traitant
automobile qui a fait faillite qui a
licencié les salariés il y a une révolte
des ouvriers ils ont brûlé les machines
la nuit etc j'ai fait venir on va
redresser cette usine et on va fabriquer
des panneaux photovoltaïques l'usine est
toujours la construction VMH et il y a
toujours des panneaux photovoltaïques
qui sont fabriqués donc il y avait ces
prouve qu'il y avait bien une
possibilité d'avancer
alors justement sur la question des
filières industrielles vous l'avez dit
dans votre propos liminaire vous venez
en quelque sorte dans le répéter ce qui
est important c'est la stratégie et la
vision à long terme pour que les
filières se structurent et souhaitent
efficaces
cet ensemble en ce sens finalement que
vous produisez une vision à long terme
notamment pour la filière nucléaire
jusqu'en 2011 vous déclarez si je ne
m'abuse qu'on peut sortir du nucléaire
en 40 ans et du coup en 2015 dans la loi
de tpcv vous vous faites voter un
objectif de plafonnement des capacités
et de réduction de la part du nucléaire
dans la loi tpcv c'est en quelque sorte
un signal à long terme qui est donné
pour la filière si je ne m'abuse
il y a plusieurs choses dans cette je me
souviens pas de cette déclaration en
2011 faudrait revoir le contexte parce
que
vous faites faire une déclaration sur le
nucléaire en 2011
c'était dans le cadre je peux vous la je
peux vous la je peux vous la lire
c'était dans le cadre des primaires du
Parti socialiste
que j'ai fait parce que j'ai dans les
déclarations sorties du contexte mais
peu importe c'est sans doute possible
mais le point important c'est celui de
des 50% d'énergie des 50% donc qui sont
dans la loi de transition énergétique
cet objectif comme vous le savez je le
reçois je suis censé le mettre en
application
puisqu'il a été annoncé donc je suis
censé le mettre en application dans
cette loi
donc dans un premier temps je dis mais
cet objectif n'a rien à faire dans la
loi moi je suis chargée de préparer la
cop21 je suis chargée d'assurer la
transition énergétique du pays donc je
vais pas prendre en charge en plus une
problématique polémique des 50 %, parce
que il va y avoir une bagarre à
l'Assemblée moi j'ai besoin de
rassembler les énergies politiques pour
qu'on ait un modèle énergétique qui soit
le plus consensuel possible
et là ça n'a pas été
possible donc on me demande de faire
voter les 50% de donc la baisse de la
part de 115 50% du nucléaire dans la
production de l'électricité à l'orée
donc c'était 2025 la promesse qui avait
été faite
j'anticipe peut-être vos questions
bon donc dans un premier temps je dis
non c'est pas un objectif qui doit être
dans ma loi pourquoi parce que pour
savoir si on est capable de maintenir ou
de baisser à 50% la part du nucléaire il
faut d'abord être sûr d'avoir réussi en
matière d'économie d'énergie et
d'énergie renouvelable si comme vous le
dites effectivement vous l'avez dit à
l'instant mais même si on consomme le
même volume d'énergie pour baisser la
part du nucléaire faut déjà être sûr
qu'on ait réussi à monter en puissance
sur les énergies renouvelables et sur
les économies d'énergie et au moment où
je vais voter la loi je ne sais pas si
on va réussir à faire monter en
puissance donc je suis dans un premier
temps j'essaye de sortir les 50% dire on
le mettra dans la PPE on verra
l'objectif il faut baisser cette part
parce qu'il faut pas faire croire non
plus que on a une énergie
abondante
à n'importe quel niveau parce que sous
prétexte qu'on aurait l'énergie
nucléaire non on doit être aussi de
rentrer dans une civilisation qui
consomme moins d'énergie qui améliore
l'autonomie énergétique de la France je
rappelle quand même que le nucléaire on
a besoin de carburant et d'uranium et
que la France n'en produit pas donc
quand on nous dit que c'est l'autonomie
énergétique c'est ça se relativise aussi
un peu alors que les énergies
renouvelables ou l'hydroélectricité ou
les autres énergies renouvelables et la
performance énergétique ça c'est
l'autonomie énergétique de la France je
n'ai pas pu donc écarter cela parce que
c'est vrai que ça faisait partie du mix
énergétique
donc ça vient dans la loi alors ma
deuxième tactique ça a été dire écoutez
moi je vais pas abîmer le débat sur la
transition énergétique et on discutera
du nucléaire à la fin
donc pour éviter qu'il y a un blocage
dès le début entre les pronoms
nucléaires les anti-nucléaires etc donc
ça ça a pas mal fonctionné et enfin j'ai
essayé de mettre l'horizon 2030
au départ parce que il y avait certains
parlementaires de l'UMP qui était
presque d'accord pour voter au moins
pour s'abstenir si on mettait 2030 donc
j'ai dit ce qui est le plus important
d'avoir un consensus que d'avoir une
bagarre ou dire à on l'a dit donc on le
met etc
et ça n'a pas donc les écologistes
remontent au créneau Matignon Élisée
tout ça bon bref et à ce moment-là on
atterrit et non on a dit 2025 et 2025
j'ai dit écoutez moi je ne mettrai pas
2025 dans la Loire
je mettrai au pire j'accepte l'horizon
donc c'est comme ça qu'on atterrit sur
l'horizon 2025 j'ai empêché le coup près
à 2025 alors ça attendait
dans tous les sens je dis maintenant ça
suffit c'est moi qui suis chargé de
cette loi de transition énergétique
c'est l'horizon 2025 ou rien ou j'enlève
de la loi donc on va céder à l'horizon
2025 ensuite il y a eu la PPE la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
donc PPE
donc à ce moment là on revient donc ce
qui est les anti-nucléaires mais c'est
leur droit à la limite ça fait réfléchir
aussi à l'épreux nucléaires ils
nucléaires moi j'essaye de comprendre
les logiques des uns et des autres il y
a du bon à prendre des deux côtés ça
force à réfléchir quand on est obligé de
prendre des décisions ça force à
s'expliquer et donc à réfléchir et à
dire pourquoi on les retient la PPE
arrive et à ce moment-là
on me dit faut mettre 16 la fermeture je
crois que c'était 16 réacteurs où on se
réacteurs de fermeture dans la loi je
dis non
il y aura pas de j'annoncerai pas la
fermeture des réacteurs dans la loi
d'abord parce qu'il y a 35000 je m'en
souviens encore de réunion terme
ministériel il y a 35000 salariés dans
les centrales nucléaires
vous m'avez pas bon j'ai pas pu mettre
2030 je pense que la part du nucléaire
c'est une résultante des autres efforts
sur les comme je viens de l'expliquer
sur l'efficacité énergétique et sur les
énergies renouvelables je ne mettrai pas
une liste de réacteurs à fermer dans la
PPE donc vous pouvez vérifier la PPE il
y a pas de liste de réacteurs
et le paradoxe c'est qu'après moi quand
j'ai quitté le ministère
mon ancienne directrice de cabinet quand
même devient ministre de l'anse de
ministre de l'Environnement
que vous avez interrogé aussi c'était le
binôme qui était à mon cabinet qui se
retrouve là il sort quand même la
fermeture de Fessenheim sans
conditionner à l'ouverture de
Flamanville
ils sortent une PPE avec une liste de
fermeture
des réacteurs
ils font une déclaration j'ai la dépêche
vous la laisserai en novembre 2019
disons à EDF tenez-vous bien qu'il faut
qu'ils imaginent un scénario à 100%
énergie renouvelable en contredisant
publiquement le Jean-Bernard Lévy qui
dit non il faut qu'il faut qu'on
commence à quand même à réfléchir aux
nouveaux réacteur par rapport à
l'arrivée en fin de vie de certains
réacteurs il se fait rappeler à l'ordre
par la ministre qui lui dit non vous
allez étudier un scénario 100% énergie
renouvelable mais comment voulez-vous
que des ingénieurs les techniciens les
ouvriers se sentent mobilisés sur
l'énergie nucléaire ne serait-ce que
pour entretenir les centrales si vous
leur dites que c'est une énergie qui va
s'arrêter
c'est impossible car aujourd'hui dans le
problème de l'entretien des centrales
notamment la corrosion qui est
d'ailleurs pas sur les anciennes
centrales qui est sur les nouvelles
centrales et j'en sais quelque chose que
dans ma région j'avais une centrale j'ai
une centrale nucléaire si vous une des
toutes dernières mises en
activité il y a des problèmes de
corrosion or c'est une des plus récentes
centrales donc on a besoin de salariés
d'ouvriers de techniciens et d'ingénieur
formés et motivés et si les centrales
sont pas assez entretenus c'est parce
que avec des déclarations comme ça vous
pouvez plus maintenir des jeunes même
pour rentrer dans ces filières
sans vouloir vous manquer de respect
est-ce que vous n'avez pas engagé ce
mouvement de signaux forts politiques
pour la pour la filière électronucléaire
française dans dans la perspective de la
fin de cette filière quand vous êtes
quand vous mettez dans votre loi qu'il
faut plafonner les capacités installées
réduire la part du nucléaire dans le mix
électrique et que vous portez la
fermeture des deux réacteurs de
Fessenheim au contraire
parce que c'était le maintien de cette
part du nucléaire par rapport à ceux qui
disaient il faut sortir du nucléaire par
rapport à ce qui disent faut imaginer un
scénario à 100% d'énergie renouvelable à
EDF au contraire et d'ailleurs dans le
décret de fermeture de Fessenheim je
prévois la fermeture que quand
Flamanville va s'ouvrir pour le maintien
justement à 63,2 Go et c'est le décret
qui va me succéder qui qui prévoit la
fermeture de Fessenheim sans
conditionner à l'ouverture de
Flamanville la seconde chose c'est que
je pense que le
critère clé c'est aussi le prix de
l'énergie
donc plus vous allez investir dans les
énergies renouvelables plus vous allez
faire baisser le prix des énergies
renouvelables et plus vous allez
lancer de nouveaux programmes de
nucléaire plus ce prix va être élevé
j'avais la comparaison des différents
prix mais aujourd'hui les prix de
nucléaire des gens installés et le prix
du renouvelable sont à peu près
équivalents le prix du nouveau nucléaire
est beaucoup plus élevé le prix de
l'éolien flottant est plus élevé aussi
parce qu'on en est au prototype donc il
faut veiller aussi
au prix de l'énergie or quand vous
regardez le parc nucléaire je pense que
c'est important aussi de plafonner
nucléaire qui est pas une fuite en avant
vers le nucléaire pourquoi parce que le
nul le nouveau nucléaire va être
beaucoup plus cher nous n'avons pas
l'autonomie énergétique avec l’uranium
on prévoit que les mines d'uranium vont
arriver à leur fin de de ressources dans
les années 2050 il y aura de nouveau
gisements en tout cas ça nous fait quand
même dépendre d'un certain nombre
d'autres pays ensuite la plupart des
centrales vont arriver en fin de vie 40
ans donc ça suppose des investissements
comme très importants de remise aux
normes et par conséquent plus la
question des déchets qui n'est pas
résolu vous avez vu ce qui vient de se
passer à Bures ou le tribunal vient de
libérer justement les militants anti
unfouissement des déchets et comment
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
enfouir des déchets honnêtement des
déchets qui ont de durée de vie de quoi
200000 ans alors qu'on a oublié les
pyramides d'Égypte en 3000 ans j'ai
toujours été moi archi hostile et je
n'ai signé aucun accord aucun sur
l'enfouissement des déchets nucléaires
je pense que c'est irresponsable par
rapport aux générations futures que ce
sont des choses qui seront oubliés dans
le sous-sol et qui un jour enfin qui
sont porteuses quand même de de
peut-être de conséquences dramatiques
donc ça je pense qu'on doit s'interdire
moralement l'enfouissement des déchets
donc vous voyez le nucléaire
présente aussi des avantages bien
évidemment parce que nous avons des
équipements amortis qui produisent de
l'énergie
mais c'est une énergie non fossiles mais
aussi beaucoup d'inconvénients donc ceux
qui sont archi pro nucléaires en disant
on va revenir au tout nucléaire non ils
n'ont pas plus raison que ceux qui
disent on va sortir d'une nucléaire donc
je pense être arrivé un bon équilibre
entre ces 50% mais sans annoncer la
fermeture des réacteurs avant d'avoir
regardé correctement les choses et pour
ne pas décourager la filière d'une part
et d'autre part pour être en place les
outils de monter en puissance des
énergies renouvelables et des économies
d'énergie je pense que l'équilibre était
était solide alors justement vous nous
avez dit dans dans votre propos
liminaire et dans vos réponses que ce
qui était important c'est que cette loi
thème CV soit accompagnée d'un pilotage
fin pour que les objectifs ne soient pas
simplement des annonces
laisser au vent quel pilotage
mettez-vous en place sur cette question
du nucléaire
le pilotage fin en matière de suivi de
l'évolution des trajectoires quand on
met dans la loi horizon 2025 j'ai bien
compris maintenant qu'on nous l'a
expliqué plusieurs fois qu'il fallait
pas forcément lire 2025 mais ça que ça
pouvait être peut-être 2027 voilà mais
bon finalement qu'est-ce que c'est que
deux années non dans le temps industriel
quoi donc quels sont les outils de
pilotage sur ce sujet là que vous
imaginez ou que vous mettez en place les
outils de pilotage ils sont assez
simples c'est à dire que on baissera la
part du nucléaire si l'augmentation de
la consommation et d'énergétique
relève essentiellement à la fois des
économies d'énergie qui peuvent donc
réorienter ailleurs et des énergies
renouvelables sinon c'est pas possible
d'arriver à 50% donc je redis ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est que moi le
pari que je faisais si on veut venir à
50 %, c'est qu'il fallait
investir très fortement dans les
énergies renouvelables et c'est pour ça
que je mets en place des outils auprès
des collectivités locales la finance
verte les citoyens le CTE pour que tout
le monde pousse en avant les énergies
renouvelables les économies d'énergie et
à ce moment-là puisque ces plafonné à
63,2 gigawatts vous voyez bien que si
l'augmentation de l'énergie relève
essentiellement des énergies
renouvelables et des économies d'énergie
et ben arithmétiquement on va baisser la
part du nucléaire puisque le nucléaire
se maintient 63,2 gigawatts
alors vous vous affichez néanmoins la
volonté de fermer deux réacteurs
de Fessenheim
qu'est-ce qui motive donc ce choix de la
fermeture des deux réacteurs de
Fessenheim alors la fermeture de
Fessenheim avait été promise donc comme
pour tous les dossiers je regarde
ce qu'on peut faire comme on peut faire
pourquoi c'est fait etc donc et puis
qu'est-ce que moi quelle plus-value je
peux apporter par rapport à la gestion
d'un problème comme celui-ci donc la
fermeture de Fessenheim l'argument
c'était de dire c'était une des plus
anciennes centrales le deuxième argument
j'ai regardé moi les arrêts des
réacteurs de Fessenheim
ils étaient souvent pâle très souvent il
y avait un ou deux réacteurs arrêtés il
faut quand même bien le dire
ensuite quand elle était une centrale
ancienne ce que j'avais vu aussi c'était
que les normes de sécurité aujourd'hui
les nouvelles centrales n'ont plus rien
à voir avec les normes de sécurité de
Fessenheim et puis il y avait un
problème aussi du niveau des tirages du
de la rivière pour le refroidissement
d'ailleurs qui se pose à toutes les
centrales parce que vous avez vu que
sinon ces derniers gros problème avec le
niveau des tirages de la Loire et par
rapport au circuit de refroidissement
donc ça aussi pays par rapport à
l'avenir du nucléaire il y au
réchauffement climatique c'est aussi un
sujet qu'il faudra quand même regarder
de près
donc à partir de là je j'engage le
processus de fermeture de Fessenheim
mais je le fais pas n'importe comment
je fais comme je me demande ce que moi
je voudrais si je présider cette région
à ce territoire
donc qu'est-ce que je prévois fait ce
Nike parce que je pense qu'il faut
jamais fermer un équipement industriel
sans imaginer sa mutation
donc je propose à ce moment là aux élus
mais vous levez peut-être vous avez
peut-être entendu parler parce que vous
étiez eu local de choses
premièrement c'était de mettre en place
la Fessenheim le un pôle d'excellence
sur le démantèlement des centrales il y
a plusieurs centaines de centrales à
l'échelle mondiale qui ont besoin de
démanteler et je me disais puisqu'on
doit demander les Fessenheim on va en
faire un pôle pilote dans le domaine du
démantèlement c'est-à-dire tous les
d'abord j'avais dit en maintiendra tous
les emplois fessennels parce qu'on a
besoin des ingénieurs pour réussir ce
démantèlement et en plus on va être
exemplaire donc on va conquérir un
marché mondial du démantèlement des
centrales
et ça j'en faisais mon affaire en disant
on avait déjà demandé qu'on fasse
l'inventaire de toutes les centrales à
démanteler quels étaient les pays qui
auraient pu être clients de qu'on
pourrait associer même à ce chantier etc
donc pour les ouvriers c'était quand
même sortir vers le haut par rapport à
leur métier leur compétences etc
premièrement et deuxièmement
j'avais imaginé d'installer sur cette
zone une usine Tesla en disant on va
montrer qu'il y avait un territoire qui
est capable d'anticiper le futur puis
comme j'étais le passionné de la voiture
électrique fait dans ma région etc et je
dis on va surtout que c'était les Alpes
il y avait les Allemands on va faire une
zone commune franco-allemande et on va
installer l'usine Tesla franco-allemande
je vais chez Tesla je visite l'usine
Tesla je fais venir le patron de Tesla
au ministère je discute avec lui je vais
voir le ministre de l'industrie
allemande et on décide de mettre en
place un processus de création de
l'usine Tesla sur cette zone
industrielle que je voulais
franco-allemande pour que les deux pays
sortent vers le haut et au moins créer
de l'emploi industriel à la place de
Fessenheim
tout ça est à peu près acté je quitte le
ministère tout ça s'arrête vous savez où
est l'usine Tesla aujourd'hui
elle est en Allemagne donc voilà donc
ils ont pas tout perdu ils ont repris
l'usine Tesla qui était mon idée en plus
c'est moi qui ai fait venir le patron de
Tesla c'est moi qui réuni le fait la
réunion avec le ministre de l'industrie
allemande et au bout du compte comme
tout est tombé à l'eau c'est les
Allemands ils ont récupéré Tesla
simplement sur les raisons de la
fermeture je serai assez preneur que
vous ne communiquez à l'issue de
l'audition les éléments que vous
indiquez notamment sur la
quotité d'arrêt des deux réacteurs de
Fessenheim comparé au reste du parc qui
semble justifier votre choix
dans le cas d'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire et qu'on essaye de
procéder à des auditions sérieuses et
sous serment
donc vous vous prenez
quelques jours avant de quitter votre
ministère
pour cause de fin de mandat présidentiel
S qui arrivent quand vous quittez le
ministère le décret de fermeture de
Fessenheim qui sera par la suite cassé
par les tribunaux
pourquoi finalement précipiter ce décret
alors que la démonstration que vous
venait de faire semblait indiquer qu'il
y avait pas
urgence absolue à se prononcer
juridiquement sur ce choix
je pense que c'est pour finaliser un
processus pour consolider peut-être
aussi le projet industriel substitution
vous avez assez largement critiqué la
façon dont du coup ça a été fermé
ensuite de façon déconnectée à
Flamanville est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir permis un autre choix
dans la préparation de la poursuite
d'exploitation de Fessenheim au cas où
Flamanville ne serait pas disponible en
temps et en heure
oui parce que parce que Fessenheim ne
devait fermer que au moment de
l'ouverture de Flamanville
pourquoi avez-vous alors demandé à EDF
de ne pas préparer les 4e visites
décennales pour Fessenheim
allait ouvrir
donc
réinvestir sur fessenal n'a pas de sens
si flamme en ville dont déjà il y a eu
un dérapage financier considérable comme
vous le savez ouvrez
puisque ce que ce que disait Dave c'est
que Flamanville allait ouvrir dans ce
que je ne voulais pas c'est qu'on
continue à investir sur Fessenheim
d'autant que j'avais préparé la mutation
industrielle du site
alors que Flamanville allait ouvrir ce
qui n'a pas été le cas parce que
Flamanville ne fonctionne toujours pas
très bien je vais poser deux dernières
questions pour
fermer le cycle des propos qui m'ont
font réagir dans ce qui vous est plus je
serai la parole en rapporteur est-ce que
lorsque vous étiez
ministre de l'Énergie vous aviez
conscience de l'effet falaise du parc
électronucléaire français vous avez
parlé des 40 ans auquel tout le monde
arrivait progressivement ce que
Fessenheim est lancé quoi que deux
années avant le reste les centrales
suivantes
et est-ce que du coup vous avez eu
connaissance de proposition de lancement
de nouveaux chantiers nucléaires autre
que Flamanville
pas ma connaissance non
en France vous voulez dire non
et du coup quelle vision est-ce que vous
aviez de
la question du cycle du combustible
notamment de la fermeture du cycle des
projets de recherche en cours comment
est-ce que vous envisagiez
l'avenir du nucléaire en France et quels
sont les décisions que vous avez pu
prendre dans la matière
je me souviens pas de décision
particulière sur les stratégies qu'on
faisait confiance à EDF le conseil
d'administration siégé le directeur
général de l'énergie donc il devait
remonter les principales décisions qui
ont eu à ce moment-là mais il y avait
pas d'autres décisions stratégique de
mémoire je me souviens pas de décision
stratégique indépendamment de celle-ci
sur concernant Fessenheim sur la
stratégie nucléaire
donc vous avez des questions je vous ai
entendu
évoquer la question des déchets donc ça
pose la question du cycle du cycle des
projets de réacteur en surgénérateur la
fermeture du cycle de la réduction des
déchets enfin voilà mais c'est des
sujets sur lesquels vous n'avez pas
forcément une action particulière
à ma connaissance il y a pas de sujet
d'arbitrage qui me sont remontés en tant
que ministre de l'énergie par rapport
aux stratégies de DF
à part les déchets nucléaires
effectivement
même si la recherche sur les
surgénérateurs étaient plutôt au CEAF
oui
très bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour ses premières réponses
peut-être une question d'ordre général
pour être sûr de pas mes interpréter vos
propos vous avez plusieurs fois parler
de d'objectifs qu'on vous avez assigné
en tant que ministre vous avez parlé de
l'horizon de 50% du nucléaire d'une
mise enfin d'une réduction de la place
du nucléaire dans notre mix vous faites
écho au président de la République de
l'époque au Premier ministre vous
semblez dire mais peut-être que je me
trompe c'est pour ça que je vous demande
de confirmer ou d'infirmer que vous en
arrivant au responsabilité en tant que
ministre en charge de l'écologie et de
l'énergie vous prenez du recul et vous
vous dites que finalement les
contraintes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement de capacité à
assurer la transition au sein du mix
énergétique et électrique vous font
prendre les choses avec peut-être plus
de prudence que les objectifs politiques
initiaux de réduction de sortie du
nucléaire est-ce que c'est à peu près ce
que vous avez dit où est-ce que je
travestis vos propos
en effet c'est à peu près ça
moi je suis attaché
comment dirais-je aux structures
industrielle du pays et je suis pas pour
bousculer léger les gens répéter tout à
l'heure il y a quand même 35000 salariés
j'ai
une centrale nucléaire dans ma région si
vous et je sais que pour être crédible
dans le domaine énergétique il faut être
capable je le répète de monter en
puissance sur le renouvelable et ça moi
j'en suis convaincu donc c'est un combat
aussi qui me plaît et je me dis bah oui
si on arrive à réduire une nucléaire à
50% parce qu'on a on aura réussi sur le
renouvelable et sur les économies
d'énergie on va c'est formidable je sais
aussi que le nucléaire a des défauts
donc je parle non plus pro-nucléaire
aveugle j'ai dit lesquels et par
conséquent je me dis bon bah à partir du
moment où c'est un objectif politique
qui a été acté
essayant de le réaliser le mieux
possible par rapport aux intérêts de la
France
voilà mais tout en
dit de faire la liste comme ça des
réacteurs c'est pas des scalpes j'ai pas
de scale pas donné
en leur donnant une liste de réacteurs à
fermer ça je me suis toujours refusée il
m'ont demandé mais c'est toujours refusé
justement
le 26 septembre 2011
dans une réponse à un questionnaire de
Greenpeace je vais dire les questions et
les réponses assez succinctement si vous
m'y autorisez monsieur le Président
à la question êtes-vous pour une sortie
du nucléaire en France si oui il y a
quel échéance vous répondez oui à
échéance de 40 ans maximum un plan
d'action sera défini dès le début du
quinquennat pour rendre irréversible ce
changement de politique énergétique à la
question êtes-vous pour ou contre
l'arrêt du chantier et l'abandon du
projet EPR de Flamanville vous répondez
pendant la campagne de 2007 je m'étais
déjà prononcé contre et si j'avais été
lu je n'aurais pas engagé ce chantier à
la question êtes-vous pour ou contre
l'abandon du projet de père de panli
vous répondez pour l'abandon à la
question le développement de la
quatrième génération doit-il être
poursuivi vous répondez contre la mise
en chantier du réacteur Astrid je
concentrerai les dépenses publiques sur
les énergies renouvelables et la
croissance verte et à la question sur le
retraitement des combustibles irradiés
et la production des MOX êtes-vous pour
ou contre l'abandon de la stratégie vous
répondez pour l'abandon je concentrerai
les dépenses publiques sur les énergies
renouvelables et la croissance verte
pourtant par la suite vous refusez
d'arrêter le chantier de l'EPR le 8
janvier 2015
au journal l'Usine Nouvelle vous
déclarez il faut maintenant programmer
les investissements de sécurité des
réacteurs existants mais il faut aussi
programmer la construction d'une
nouvelle génération de réacteurs qui
prendront la place des anciennes
centrales lorsque celle-ci ne pourront
plus être rénovées donc ce que je vous
propose c'est déclarations qui
pourraient paraître contradictoires mais
qui je suis sûr ne le sont pas c'est les
prendre les unes après les autres est-ce
que lorsque vous arrivez aux
responsabilités en 2014 vous souhaitez
sortir du nucléaire à échéance de 40 ans
maximum comme vous l'indiquez en réponse
à ce questionnaire de Greenpeace en 2011
ou est-ce que les circonstances les
faits que vous découvrez au ministère
vous ont fait changer d'avis
je pense moi je suis j'ai toujours été
convaincue sur les énergies
renouvelables
je pense que le modèle énergétique
français quand je m'exprime c'est que je
sais que le modèle énergétique français
pourrait déjà être plus équilibré que le
tout nucléaire je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure parce que nous sommes aussi en
France les inventeurs de l'énergie
solaire et de l'énergie éolienne et
comme vous le savez le programme
énergétique nucléaire n'a fait l'objet
en France d'aucun débat d'ailleurs la
loi de transition énergétique c'est la
première fois la représentation
nationale débat sur le modèle
énergétique français avant c'était
uniquement des décisions de pouvoir
exécutif et je pense que quand il y a
des décisions du pouvoir
exécutifs nucléaires l'ont emporté
d'ailleurs ils ont fait comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure quand même un
équipement prodigieux du pays mais je
pense que ça a été déséquilibré y
compris par rapport à notre autonomie
énergétique et par rapport à l'uranium
parce qu'il y a non seulement la Sûreté
Nucléaire la sécurité nucléaire quand
vous êtes ministre de l'énergie par
exemple vous suivez le transport des
super dangereuse des matières nucléaires
donc je peux vous dire que c'est quand
même vous dites c'est voilà
il faut d'équilibrer ça parce qu'un jour
ça y est il y aura des problèmes qui ne
sont pas résolus les déchets nucléaires
ne sont pas résolus donc la
problématique comme je m'exprime en 2011
c'était la nécessité de rééquilibrer le
nucléaire j'ai pas les outils je suis
pas mini donc j'ai pas les outils
techniques et les et comment dirais-je
et le calcul absolument juste mais
c'était
une une déclaration d'une volonté que je
ne renie absolument pas par rapport à
tout ce qui dénigrer à l'époque fallait
voir comment on entendait parler de
l'énergie des énergies renouvelables en
2011 c'était n'importe quoi c'était les
babacs cool c'était on retourne à la
bougie etc il y avait un tir de barrage
contre toutes les énergies renouvelables
et moi je sentais que c'était pas le
sens de l'histoire que le sens de
l'histoire si il fallait diminuer sans
doute les investissements dans le
nucléaire et avec cette masse d'argent
réinvestir dans les énergies
renouvelables donc c'était l'expression
de la volonté d'un tournant énergétique
majeur que j'aurai le bonheur de faire
en 2014 peu de temps après finalement
je vous remercie je me permets juste de
revenir sur ma question parce que le 26
septembre 2011 quand on vous demande si
vous voulez sortir du nucléaire et si
oui à quelle échéance vous répondez oui
à échéance de 40 ans maximum et le 21
mai 2014 dans le cadre de votre audition
devant la commission d'enquête sur le
coup du nucléaire vous répondez je ne
pense pas au contraire du rapporteur de
la commission que l'on puisse sortir du
nucléaire ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
comprendre le cheminement qui vous
conduit à penser que visiblement
contrairement à ce que vous avez déclaré
il faut rester dans le nucléaire est-ce
que c'est la prise de responsabilité
c'est quelques jours après votre prise
de fonction est-ce que vous avez des
éléments qui vous font vous dire que
finalement c'était peut-être un peu
précipité ou dangereux de sortir du
nucléaire à court échéance c'est à dire
à 10 ou 40 ans
je ne sais pas dans quelles conditions
j'ai pu donner cette interview sortir du
nucléaire en 40 ans ça me paraît curieux
donc je sais pas quelles conditions
je pense que dans cette interview
ce que je veux absolument dire c'est que
le tout nucléaire n'est pas une solution
que la montre que ça suffit d'entendre
dénigrer les énergies renouvelables et
l'efficacité énergétique parce que c'est
qu'il y avait l'interdiction presque de
parler vous parliez du nucléaire ou du
de l'éolien à ce moment-là ou du solaire
vous étiez considéré comme des zombies
donc je pense que cette volonté de de
dire et d'ailleurs si ces énergies
renouvelables avaient été prise au
sérieux beaucoup plus tôt je suis sûr
que la France aurait des industries
extrêmement performantes dans ces
domaines et qu'aujourd'hui on n'aurait
pas les problèmes que l'on a aujourd'hui
donc bon c'était peut-être un peu
schématiquement exposé mais je ne renie
rien de ce que ça révélé alors ces
techniques j'avais peut-être pas les
éléments techniques pour le dire mais je
ne renie rien de l'inspiration que de
cette prise de parole effectivement
quand j'arrive aux responsabilités de
façon opérationnelle il faut mettre en
place il faut mettre en place les choses
c'est pas encore en tant qu'on peut
sortir du nucléaire et on peut en sortir
je vous remercie je vais effectivement
bientôt en venir aux énergies
renouvelables mais juste deux petites
dernières questions sur le nucléaire
peut-être comprendre quel a été votre
position sur la filière MOX alors pardon
pour le les personnes qui nous écoutent
c'est donc ce qui se fait dans l'usine
aura nos de lag et qui permet de
recycler une partie du combustible usé
nucléaire et qui permet donc de réduire
notre dépendance que vous avez soulignée
à l’uranium qu'on importe et vous
semblez dire en 2011 je sais pas quel
est votre position ensuite en tant que
ministre je me suis pas retrouvé
déclaration mais quel est votre position
en tant que ministre sur cette filière
de recyclage qui permet justement de
réduire cette dépendance est-ce que vous
êtes amené à à avoir un certain nombre
de décisions à prendre est-ce que vous
êtes en contact avec l'entreprise ourano
avec d'autres entreprises de recyclage
est-ce que la question du recyclage et
de l'autonomie en combuste enfin d'une
plus grande autonomie en combustible se
pose ou est-ce que finalement c'est un
sujet qui est assez peu abordé pendant
la période où vous êtes aux
responsabilités
pas de décision technique opérationnelle
mais c'est une filière que je soutiens
et je soutiens je me souviens être allé
à une réunion du Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives parce qu'on dit toujours
CEA mais faut pas oublier que c'est
derrière le CEA il y a énergie
alternative aussi
où il réfléchissait justement sur la
nouvelle génération de centrales de
façon plus petite notamment des unités
plus petites et sur la question du
retraitement du des débats si parce que
c'est une solution déchets et c'est bien
pour ça d'ailleurs que je m'oppose à
l'enfouissement parce que je dis mais
peut-être qu'un jour on aura les
technologies qui permettent de recycler
les déchets nucléaires pour en faire un
nouveau du combustible le cycle du
combustible donc bien sûr c'est si c'est
une filière importante
alors justement ma dernière question sur
le nucléaire elle porte sur les déchets
je suis pas sûr de comprendre pourquoi
vous semblez parler d'irréversibilité en
ce qui concerne le stockage en couche
profonde puisque sauf erreur sur le
contrôle des membres de la commission et
du président le projet sigo est
justement un projet qui prévoit la
civilité et la possibilité
pendant les
nombre de décennies en cours mais il est
assez important en fonction de
l'évolution de la recherche de récupérer
ces déchets si d'aventure on n'avait par
exemple des réacteurs de quatrième
génération qui permettait de d'absorber
les déchets ou qu'on avait trouvé des
expérimentations des recherches en cours
sur les lasers qui permettaient de
réduire la radioactivité de ces déchets
donc je suis pas sûr de comprendre ce
que vous voulez dire par le fait que le
choix du stockage des déchets en couche
profonde
anilerait le choix pour les générations
futures
qu'il y a un aléa considérable dans
combien de temps on va aller jusque
représente l'enfouissement des déchets
c'est pas dans deux ans qu'on va les
rechercher les déchets sinon les stocke
en surface donc il y a une contradiction
entre le fait de dire ces réversible il
fait dire mais à ce moment stocker les
en surface sur les sites des centrales
nucléaires puisqu'elles sont sécurisées
c'est pas crédible de dire qu'on enfouie
des déchets et comme je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure on a oublié les ce qu'il
y avait dans les pyramides d'Égypte en
3000 ans les déchets ils sont
radioactifs quoi 100000 ans et on va les
mettre dans le dans le sous-sol mais qui
s'en souviendra
vous voyez c'est c'est plus les risques
de tremblements de terre de de
contamination des nappes phréatiques on
maîtrise pas les choses
pas vu pas pris alors cachant les choses
donc le problème n'existe pas je me
souviens avoir dit ça mais c'est pas
parce qu'on s'est enfouie que le
problème n'existe plus moi je pense moi
je sens moi je me sens pas de prendre la
responsabilité pour les générations qui
viennent d'enfouir des déchets
radioactifs dans le sous-sol je suis
désolé mais moi je suis pas venu sur
terre pour laisser aux générations qui
suivent une terre avec des déchets
radioactifs dans le sous-sol je dis non
c'est viscéral je dis non
je vous remercie dans ce que je
comprends c'est que vous êtes pour le
stockage en surface
d'accord
j'en viens justement à la loi des 50%
pour replacer dans le contexte qu'on a
fait un certain nombre de d'auditions
Laurent Michel le directeur général
l'énergie et du climat de l'époque n'a
pas souhaité reprendre mon terme quand
je lui ai demandé si juger que
l'hypothèse de 50% à un horizon 2025 ou
2030 était réaliste il a plutôt qualifié
ça de plausible monsieur Abadie
directeur général de l'énergie de
l'époque a estimé que c'était ni un
horizon ni un comment dirais-je une
quotité raisonnable à court terme et
Monsieur Brotte a jugé que l'objectif de
50% était purement politique pour
reprendre ses mots et d'ailleurs que
ensuite lorsqu'il était devenu président
directeur général de RTE il avait pu
constater le danger que ça posait en
matière de réseau à court terme et
Monsieur Valls que nous avons auditionné
jeudi à considérer qu'il n'y avait pas
eu d'études d'impact solide sur cette
loi donc il y a relatif consensus il me
semble parmi les auditionnés quel est le
regard de la ministre de l'écologie de
l'époque de quels éléments vous proposer
en termes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement en termes de
capacité du réseau à tenir vous avez
évoqué l'horizon 2025 ou l'horizon 2030
effectivement c'est une un élément mais
de manière plus générale au-delà de
cette de cette différence de 5 ans quels
sont les éléments techniques
scientifiques technologiques dont vous
disposez qui vous permettent de penser
que cet objectif peut être tenu à ce
terme
les éléments c'est un élément de comment
dirais-je d'objectif à atteindre donc ça
la décision elle a été prise avant que
j'arrive au ministère de l'Environnement
mais je l'assume comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure pour moi c'est une
résultante les 50%. c'est à dire je me
dis que si même l'objectif est
irréaliste la preuve c'est que je plaide
pour 2030 on atterrit sur l'horizon 2025
il y a la PPE c'est à dire qu'il sera
capable de réajuster les choses en
fonction de la faisabilité ou pas mais
je qualifierai cet objectif comme un
objectif
résultant c'est un résultat de ce qu'on
a sera capable de faire donc je
transforme finalement cette contrainte
ou cette injonction politique
en action positive c'est je me dis bon
on a ça comment est-ce que j'en tire le
meilleur profit pour le modèle
énergétique français c'est en poussant
en avant les énergies renouvelables et
les économies d'énergie d'une part
si en maintenant la production d'autres
parts c'est-à-dire c'est quand même
maintenu à 63,2 Go c'est à dire en de
baisse pas la production ça c'est quand
même important à dire c'est en
conditionnant la fermeture du Fessenheim
par l'ouverture de flamants ville
c'est le troisième élément et par
conséquent c'est
voilà les choses sont mises en place par
rapport à la capacité que l'on a ou pas
de monter en puissance
je vous remercie j'avoue que il y a
quelque chose que je comprends pas en
fait parce que vraiment je suis un peu
perdu comment est-ce que les deux
directeurs en place à l'administration
du ministère en charge de l'énergie
peuvent nous dire avec beaucoup de
franchise franchise à la limite de du
désarment sans jeu de mots
qu'il n'y a pas d'étude d'impact
sérieuse et d'horizon à court terme que
celui qui devient ensuite président
directeur général de RTE en charge du
réseau de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la capacité du
réseau à assumer cette charge peut nous
dire qu'il découvre ensuite que ce n'est
pas possible et que vous nous expliquez
que finalement c'était un objectif qui
s'il était suivi de manière rigoureuse
et année après année ne posez pas de
problème j'ai l'impression qu'il que et
c'est une question vraiment ouverte
c'est à dire que j'ai l'impression que
il y a quelque chose de très intéressant
dans ce que vous dites c'est que c'est
absolument contredictoire avec tout ce
que nous ont dit nos interlocuteurs
précédents et je vous pose la question
sans bien sûr avoir la réponse c'est
comment est-ce que vous vous percevez
cette apparente contradiction
pu me permettre aussi sans vouloir vous
offenser c'est
la logique de votre question
est encore plus forte si vous interrogez
la personne qui dit que il faut un
scénario à 100% d'énergie renouvelable
vous êtes d'accord parce que là au moins
moi je me fais les 50% et je ferme pas
un Fessenheim sans la réouverture de
flammes en ville et il y a quelqu'un
derrière qui vient dire 100% d'énergie
renouvelable donc votre question encore
plus de plus d'impact je reviens aux
déclarations des autres donc le
directeur général de l'énergie je crois
Laurent Michel qui dit que
le directeur général de l'énergie et du
climat qui ne veut pas dire que les
hypothèses étaient réalistes mais
qu'elles étaient plausibles et le
directeur général de l'énergie qui à
vous que il n'y avait pas d'études très
robuste qui permettait de de le faire et
d'ailleurs à ma boutade selon laquelle
c'était grave mais pas suffisamment pour
qu'il démissionne approuve
et puis François brode qui dit que
c'est quand même le plus étonnant c'est
de sa part parce qu'il est quand même
rapporteur je suis pendant des heures à
mes côtés en dans le ministre il est
rapporteur de la loi
donc il fait voter les 50%. je me
souviens pas qui ce soit opposé
d'ailleurs
y compris sur la PPE il est pour la
fermeture d'un certain nombre de
réacteurs c'est moi qui le nomme
d'ailleurs à RTE donc il faut faire
attention aussi vous voyez aux gens qui
changent de position et puis en fonction
de leur posture qui change de position
moi je le fais jamais ça donc ce que je
crois c'est que l'objectif de 50% c'est
un accord politique entre le PS et les
Verts et que cet accord politique il
signifie quoi il est pas techniquement
robuste comme vous le dites par rapport
à des études d'impact etc d'ailleurs ils
ont pas les moyens de faire des études
d'impact bon
c'est un objectif politique au sens où
il faut sortir nucléaire
je le pense aussi donc j'assume cet
objectif c'est pour moi qui négocié
discuter j'aurais peut-être pas fait
sous cette forme là mais j'assume qu'il
faut sortir du tout nucléaire pour les
raisons que l'on a dit mais il faut le
sortir raisonnablement du tout nucléaire
y compris pour des questions
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
du coût de l'énergie également
et de la compétition mondiale sur le sur
les énergies renouvelables je signale
d'ailleurs que à l'échelle mondiale la
production nucléaire est aujourd'hui
représente moins de 10% de la production
énergétique mondiale et la production
d'énergie renouvelable soléolien
représente 15% de la production énergie
mondiale donc vous voyez que même la
compétition dans le monde et je parlais
tout à l'heure de la Chine avec les
raccordements accélérés au solaire et
aux autres énergies renouvelables font
que nous devons pas prendre de en retard
et que si on s'aligne sur une posture
idéologie anti-nucléaire ou une posture
idéologique pro-nucléaire on fera les
mêmes erreurs c'est à dire on va
désarmer la France par rapport aux
investissements que nous devons
absolument faire dans la compétition
mondiale sur la question de l'efficacité
énergétique des bâtiments sur le sur les
transports propres et sur les énergies
renouvelables et moi je rêverais de la
France que la France puisse quand même
faire sur son sol des des panneaux
photovoltaïques alors j'ai fait mon
petit niveau dans ma région
miraculeusement pas miraculeusement
parce que l'entreprise est bien gérée
elle continue d'ailleurs ce sont ces
panneaux solaires que j'ai utilisé pour
mettre sur les maternités en brousse en
Afrique ce que je crée une ONG avec les
femmes africaines à la Coop donc il y a
du potentiel on a les mais on a de très
bons ingénieurs il y a aucune raison
qu'on n'y arrive pas mais si vous dites
aux gens bah non il y a pas besoin
d'économiser l'énergie il y a pas besoin
d'énergie renouvelable parce qu'on a le
nucléaire
et puis on va en refaire encore
on leur dit mais à quel prix on bossant
on va passer de 50 euros à 150 euros non
le prix aussi c'est quelque chose
d'important pour le pour les
consommateurs
je vous remercie alors justement sur les
énergies renouvelables parce que vous
avez dit quelque chose qui résonne avec
un certain nombre d'auditions sur l'idée
que si on veut pouvoir
développer les énergies renouvelables
sur notre territoire il faut avoir les
filières industrielles et vous avez
parlé de de d'initiative que vous avez
menées et de la conviction très forte
qui fait d'ailleurs avec OSL de Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet qu'on a auditionné la
semaine dernière et qui parlait de
certains parcs et le lien flottants dans
la chaîne de valeur industrielles des
énergies renouvelables on sait
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on le sait
depuis un petit moment qu'il y a les
matériaux critiques les métaux rares la
capacité à disposer de ces matériaux
pour construire une industrie donc
j'imagine que à l'époque c'est une de
vos préoccupations centrales puisque
vous voulez que le mix énergétique
énergétique soit composée à 50%
d'énergie renouvelables donc quelle
mesure vous prenez à partir de 2014 pour
que l'approvisionnement matériaux
critique soit développé sur notre sol
parce qu'on sait qu'on en a et puis pour
sécuriser les approvisionnements les
diversifier et pour qu'on soit le plus
possible indépendant en terme de chaîne
de valeur
chacun son métier
tri l'état elle rend solvable à marcher
et attractif un marché comment je rend
le marché attractif en faisant la
finance verte j'ai détaillé tout à
l'heure et en lançant tous les appels à
projets dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables c'est quoi un appel à
projet c'est que ça garantit aux
industriels des commandes c'est leur
garantie un prix de rachat de l'énergie
donc ça la garantit un business model
rentable qui leur permet d'investir et
après c'est à eux d'avoir recours et de
rechercher les marchés des des matériaux
rares
mais je pense que chacun est dans son
métier et moi je considérais que
dans la tradition d'ailleurs du
volontarisme énergétique français que
la question des appels d'offres des
appels à projets étaient quelque chose
de très dynamique et qui permettait aux
industriels d'investir ce qui d'ailleurs
ce qui est d'ailleurs ils ont fait
je vous remercie justement sur le prix
de l'électricité
me permet de resituer rapidement un
échange avec l'ancien président de la
creux de la Commission de régulation
sur la reine notamment et je me permets
si une autorise de citer notre collègue
Francis Dubois qui pose une question à
Monsieur de Ladoucette et j'espère que
vous m'en voudrez pas cher collègues
posez votre question j'espère que je ne
vous coupe pas l'air sous le pied mais
elle me paraît dans le contexte encore
plus important vous dites chers
collègues je me demande si la creux a le
pouvoir de rappeler à l'état que cette
actualité celle de la reine c'est-à-dire
la capacité à actualiser le prix que que
devait le prix de l'arène le tarif de la
reine est obligatoire si nous souhaitons
que le producteur en l'occurrence EDF ne
soit pas déséquilibré et que le tarif de
42 euros le mégawattheure évolue bien
avec le temps pour que EDF ne soit pas
déséquilibré la réponse de Monsieur de
La doucette est la suivante nous avons
souvent posé cette question je cite à
l'exécutif et à l'administration entre
le 21 juillet 2014 et les deux ans et
demi qui ont suivi ensuite les
discussions se sont arrêtées et nous
n'avons pas le pouvoir d'interpeller le
gouvernement vous pourrez cependant
poser cette question à Madame Royale je
me sentais donc le de de rapporteur de
vous poser cette question de de savoir
quelles ont été vos réflexions sur la
reine et donc sur cette question de du
tarif auquel EDF était tenu de revendre
son électricité produite pourtant un
coup qui selon les responsables anciens
responsable de def à un prix qui ne
correspondait pas au coût de production
il est un scandale
et qui est à l'interface entre une
idéologie libérale le marché va tout
résoudre miraculeusement et les
injonctions européennes faut libéraliser
le marché bien sûr c'est l'intérêt du
consommateur
et cette arène qui a été mise en place
reine dans l'accès régulier à
l'électricité nucléaire historique a
conduit EDF avant ta perte
avant le rappel c'est à dire que sont
intervenus du coup sur ce segment du
marché de la commercialisation qui dès
lors été libéralisée entre la production
et la vente des vautours
des spéculateurs mais c'est la
réglementation qui leur a permis de
spéculer pourquoi parce que ils
achetaient en dessous du prix de
production donc c'est nous qui avons
payé les centrales nucléaires
l'hydroélectricité c'est quand même la
France et nous
et
EDF était obligé de vendre à perte quand
c'est quand même aberrant et quand alors
on voyait pas au début parce qu'au début
comme l'énergie n'augmentait pas trop je
vais revenir parce qu'à un moment j'ai
bloqué le prix de l'énergie pour
empêcher ce que tu vas te
et là quand la flambée du prix de
l'énergie vous rendez compte ce qui
s'est passé c'est que des gens qui ne
produisent pas qui achètent à perte qui
revendent au prix du marché à une sur le
prix du gaz russe en poche la différence
et on fait rien on fait rien en face on
fait rien pourquoi parce qu'il y a la
pression de la pseudo-rélementation
européenne qui d'ailleurs a été est mal
et mal appliqué en dans ce domaine là et
deuxièmement les opérateurs qui sont
venus sur ce segment n'ont même pas
rempli leurs obligations ce sera
intéressant d'ailleurs une commission
d'enquête
sur l'utilisation de la reine qui s'est
enrichie qui est venue sur ce créneau
comment ils ont fait et pourquoi ils
n'ont pas été sanctionnés quand ils
n'ont pas tenu leur engagement
cette école les engagements des
opérateurs c'est quoi le engagement
toujours aujourd'hui d'ailleurs des
opérateurs qui viennent sur ce créneau
c'est l'obligation de produire de
l'énergie quelle était la raison pour
laquelle on leur a été autorisé enfin on
leur a donné la capacité d'acheter de
l'énergie en dessous du prix de
production c'est parce qu'en
contrepartie de ce profit ils étaient
obligés à leur tour de créer des
filières de production d'énergie ce qui
est complètement absurde d'ailleurs
parce que du coup je vois pas comment
ils peuvent construire des des réacteurs
nucléaires ou construire des barrages
électriques donc ils n'ont pas rempli
leurs obligations dans ce domaine là et
ce qui est pire que tout c'est qu'ils
ont laissé des gens en rade il y a
certains opérateurs qui ont fait des
publicités on les a vu à la télé les
publicités venaient chez nous l'énergie
moins cher quitter EDF et puis venez
vous venez prendre l'abonnement chez
nous donc les gens notamment ceux qui
ont le moins d'argent qui regardent
leurs factures ils ont changé
d'opérateur et au moment où c'était pas
suffisamment rentable les opérateurs
disparaissent ils mettent la queue sous
la porte sauf qu'ils ont entre-temps ils
ont en fiche ils ont empoché la
différence le pire le pire c'est que
c'est l'état aussi qui était obligé
d'acheter son électricité un opérateur
privé vous savez ça
l'État a dû acheter qui qui a eu le
marché de la fourniture de l'électricité
de l'État est-ce que l'État à
l'électricité qui marche partout dans
les ministères est-ce que c'est à EDF
qu'on l'achète non
on a l'état l'État français qui quand
même est actionnaire de DF a été obligé
d'acheter son énergie sur le marché
libre par l'entreprise hydropion qui a
obtenu le marché de la fourniture de
l'électricité de l'État et cette
entreprise a fait faillite fin 2021 à
déposé le bilan mais entre-temps empoché
toutes les plus-values qu'elle a pu
faire et aujourd'hui l'État retourne
chez EDF avec la hausse des prix entre
temps est-ce que vous rendez compte de
l'aberration du système donc oui la
réponse est oui il faut dénoncer ce
système il faut en sortir et si je
pouvais prolonger quand il y a eu j'ai
moi aussi j'étais donc là c'était fait
c'était fait depuis 2010 moi j'ai jamais
été saisi pour supprimer la reine ou
quoi que ce soit en plus c'était moins
visible
les plus-values à ce moment là parce que
là c'est très visible parce que comme il
y a une flambée du prix de l'énergie
c'est beaucoup plus visible
mais la seconde chose c'est que quand il
y a eu l'arrivée à échéance des
concessions de démarrage de
l'hydroélectricité j'ai reçu une note
communatoire de la Commission européenne
me disant vous allez remettre sur le
marché en libre concurrence les
concessions
je me suis dit bizarre je voyais moi
j'ai toujours admiré les chantiers des
des barrages ou certainement
extraordinaire des ingénieurs français
les ouvriers tout ça qui sont morts pour
construire les barrages fallait voir les
conditions de travail je dis mais c'est
quand même bizarre puis que la Compagnie
nationale du Rhône était de beaux outils
ça remettant concession des choses qu'on
a payé nous depuis des générations avec
nos factures et puis n'importe qui
quelles entreprises faire juste
l'opérateur sur la revente d'énergie
j'ai dit non donc on m'a menace on m'a
menacé la France je suis plus une
pénalité par jour je dis la commissaire
européenne de venir me voir au ministère
on dit que je ne mettrai pas la mise en
je ne remettrai pas la mise en
concurrence parce que moi j'ai j'ai
piloté l'accord de Paris sur le climat
donc j'ai décalé le raisonnement ce qui
aurait pu être fait au moment de la
reine j'ai décalé le raisonnement en
disant apportez-moi je le redis les
barrages hydroélectriques c'est de
l'énergie renouvelable c'est de
l'énergie 0 carbone et donc si vous
m'obligez à remettre en marché les
concessions je ne suis pas l'abri d'une
hausse des prix et moi je considère que
c'est contraire à l'accord de Paris sur
le climat l'accord de Paris sur le
climat dit qu'il faut monter en
plusieurs sur les énergies renouvelables
si on veut monter en puissance soit
générer chez renouvelable il faut pas
augmenter le prix des énergies
renouvelables donc je considère que la
mise sur le marché la réouverture à
concurrence des concessions qui arrivent
à échéance dans le domaine de
l'hydroélectricité et contraire à
l'accord de Paris sur le climat et donc
je ne le ferai pas et ben l'argument a
pesé et je n'ai pas eu les sanctions ce
qui veut dire que en politique en
stratégie en réflexion en imagination
vous voyez il y a toujours moyen quand
quelque chose s'en parle pas équitable
et pas juste
de rechercher les arguments pour faire
en sorte que ce soit des arguments
justes structurés solides qui
l'emportent et sur la reine ça n'a pas
été le cas puisque 2010 d'ailleurs la
même année que la réforme du système de
retraite c'était une idée logique qui
pensait
dans leur logique que ça allait produire
une baisse du prix de l'énergie où je ne
sais pas un marché dynamique elle est
produire de l'énergie en plus mais non
c'est le contraire c'est à dire EDF a
été spolié et nous aussi au passage
mais quand vous êtes responsabilité ce
mécanisme a déjà commencé les objectifs
d'installation des différents pros de
fournisseurs alternatifs les objets
objectifs ils ne sont pas ni même
atteints ils sont pas en passe d'être
atteint les prix négatifs ils ont déjà
eu lieu donc vous dites on ne m'a pas
saisi pour aller contre la reine mais je
comprends pas qui aurait dû vous saisir
en fait si vous trouvez que c'est un
scandale pourquoi est-ce que vous n'avez
pas agi
à l'époque on a c'était la
réglementation européenne j'ai agi j'ai
réagi sur les concessions quand les
décisions identiques sont venus à ma
décision j'ai dit non et puis je pense
qu'à l'époque la flambée du prix de
l'énergie
n'était pas celle d'aujourd'hui ça c'est
la seconde chose et la troisième raison
j'ai agi moi en refusant la hausse du
prix de l'énergie parce que la hausse du
prix de l'énergie qui m'est demandé par
EDF à ce moment-là c'était pour dire on
vend l'énergie à perte donc nous aussi
faut qu'on empoche des démarches
moi je sais pas j'ai pas moi qui l'ai
mis en place ce système et donc comme
les gens sont très sensibles à la
question de la hausse du prix de
l'énergie et que il y avait pas d'autres
justificatifs de la part de DF au niveau
de la raison de hausse du prix de
l'énergie qui en effet j'avais dit on va
bloquer le prix de l'énergie et puis
peut-être ça aurait dû être peut-être
l'occasion effectivement de remettre à
plat
un mécanisme mais c'était quand même
très verrouillé puisque ça avait été à
la fois décidé
imposé par l'Europe et sans doute qui
aurait dû être fait
c'est de contrôler que les opérateurs
allaient bien produire de l'énergie
aussi mais là qu'est-ce qui nous disait
les opérateurs non mais c'est très long
de produire de l'énergie vous comprenez
on est sur le marché ça a été fait en
2010 alors 2011 2012 le temps que ils
viennent sur les opérateurs en deux ans
on n'a pas eu le temps de de trois ans
on n'a pas eu le temps de deux ans même
de construire des équipements
énergétiques mais on va le faire
et puis aujourd'hui on voit le résultat
mais alors qu'est-ce que vous leur avez
dit
parce qu'ils vous ont dit on n'a pas eu
le temps de le faire vous avez l'air
assez sceptique sur le leur engagement
et leur capacités à le faire comment
est-ce que vous avez réagi à cette non
atteinte des objectifs
j'étais pas en interlocutrice
quotidienne avec avec eux ça se passait
au niveau des services quand le service
me parlait de ça je dis soit vous vous
contrôlez
qui remplissent vraiment leurs
obligations soit c'est un problème en
revanche j'en ai tiré la leçon pour les
concessions il y aurait pas eu ce
problème là peut-être que je n'aurais
pas vu voir j'aurais pas vu venir
les dégâts qu'auraient causé et la
remise sur le marché des concessions à
leur échéance
mais c'est pas trop tard pour pour leur
demander soit de rembourser ce qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui si vous faites une
commission d'enquête c'est soit les
faire que ces opérateurs qui voient
combien de profits ont fait sur le dos
de du pays de la nation finalement et
s'ils n'ont pas rempli leurs obligations
de production d'énergie c'est de les
faire rembourser
c'est faire rembourser à EDF la logique
aujourd'hui la justice serait que ces
opérateurs voir ce qu'ils ont gagné si
c'est uniquement
en étant trader et spéculateur sur
l'énergie tout ce qu'ils ont gagné c'est
de rembourser à EDF voilà
une toute dernière question parce que on
a voté récemment je crois que en ce
moment même le Sénat va une loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables on a déjà largement parlé
vous avez exprimé le
fait que vous avez vous êtes battu pour
le développement des énergies
renouvelables au cours de votre mandat
qu'est-ce qui vous a semblé freiner se
développements des énergies
renouvelables et qu'elles sont selon
vous encore aujourd'hui les freins qui
nécessiteraient d'être levés
ce qui freine ce que j'essaie de lever
en tout cas est-ce que je réussis à
lever jusqu'à ce que ça soit interrompu
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est-à-dire le
moyen pour les gens de faire les travaux
d'économie d'énergie puis le crédit
d'impôt c'était quand même 8000 euros
par personne 16000 euros pour un couple
donc c'était beaucoup ça a cité vraiment
à faire des des travaux sans condition
de ressources c'est-à-dire sans papa
brasserie aujourd'hui il y a la prime
rénale la prime rénov je sais pas si
vous avez vu le dossier la prime rénove
c'est toujours intéressant de voir ce
que les gens voient voyez si vous
demandez une prime rien moi j'ai la
curiosité de regarder le dossier prime
rénov il y a 10 pages le crédit d'impôt
il y a trois cases à remplir et en plus
il y a une il y avait une fusion des
travaux c'est à dire que avant parce que
le service fiscaux ça a bien inventé des
règles d'allègement fiscaux pour que ça
marche pas
qui font des trucs qui n'auront jamais
de compte à rendre sur rien et qui
rattrape au moment des changements
ministériels les arbitrages sur lesquels
ils ont été battus c'est insupportable
et sur les territoires énergies positifs
la Cour des comptes avait mis des
objections et la personne qui a émis des
objections devient directrices donc elle
a détruit les territoires énergies
positifs le crédit d'impôt de transition
énergétique
les fonctionnaires qui ont été battus
dans les arbitrages se sont retrouvés au
cabinet du ministre crédit d'impôt était
supprimé donc voyez ce qui je tire de
cette expérience qu'il faut de la
continuité vous voyez moi quand je suis
arrivé ça a beaucoup bougé au ministère
de l'écologie après votre départ est-ce
que vous pouvez être un peu plus précise
sur qui prend quelle place
elle devient directrice de cabinet de
Nicolas Hulot et à la Cour des comptes
elle était phachement hostile au
territoire énergie positive en disant
que c'était exorbitant des et en fait
après ça a été jugé à la Cour des
comptes et ça a été considéré comme
parfaitement régulier donc
voilà donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique des choses qui sont comme ça
moyen terme à long terme ou les
entreprises ont besoin de stabilité
quand quelque chose est cassé il
faudrait une étude d'impact sur
ce que vont impacter ces changements y
compris au Parlement oui parce que c'est
quand même le Parlement qui vote
Parlement vois de la loi de transition
énergétique derrière ces changer il
Parlement
et il n'y a pas d'examens de quels sont
les inconvénients de changer de pied de
casser ce qu'on fait les gens avant etc
c'est ça qui va pas
quand il y a eu le Grenelle de
l'environnement quand j'étais mise de
l'environnement on vient me voir en
disant ben non il y a le Grenelle de
l'environnement il faut tout changer je
dis mais non prenez le environnement
c'était pas de mon bord politique mais
non faut de la continuité et dans la loi
de transition énergétique je Cie dans
les poser des motifs le Grenelle de
l'environnement c'est moi qui le fait de
ma propre responsabilité je veux dire on
va s'inscrire dans la continuité mais
vous avez autour de vous des conseillers
qui disent ah bah non c'est ceux d'avant
faut changer mais non on change pas ce
qu'on fait les gens d'avance si ce qui a
été fait a été bon c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'il continuité les
travaux qui sont fait quel que soit les
alternances politiques
nécessaire qualité des études d'impact
donc Premier ministre que vous servir à
souligner l'absence sur certains
éléments de la loi à tête CV alors je
vais passer la parole au début de tes
membres de la commission monsieur Vibert
oui madame la ministre
je vous avoue que j'ai eu un petit peu
de mal à
suivre à suivre votre exposé bon
j'entends bien que
et le rapporteur
l'a mis en avant dans les questions
qu'il a pu vous poser qu'à un moment
donné effectivement
vos déclarations ne soient pas je dirais
les mêmes quelques années après parce
que finalement voilà on évolue tous par
rapport par rapport à une situation
qui était extrêmement complexe que celle
du mix énergétique mais ma question sera
assez simple est-ce que en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre au
travers de votre exposé est-ce que vous
considérez que cet accord politique
entre le PS et les Verts qui consistait
à arbitrairement finalement à descendre
à 50% en ne sachant pas si c'était
quelque chose de de le raisonnable ou
pas de faisable ou pas vous le
qualifieriez de
d'erreur d'erreurs politiques majeure
c'est pas dans mon tempérament de
rétropédaler si vous voulez
rembobiner le fil de l'histoire
la politique c'est aussi des choix des
arbitrages des accords bon celui-ci je
l'ai expliqué comment moi je l'avais
interprété moi qui ai eu la
responsabilité de le mettre en
application comment j'essaie de le faire
de façon positive pour le pays en disant
bah c'est vrai que ça veut dire que
c'est le colle tout nucléaire c'est pas
une un bon un bon choix et à partir de
là comment est-ce que je m'appuie
là-dessus pour donner à la France des
opportunités supplémentaires d'être en
avance sur les énergies renouvelables et
sur la performance énergétique tout en
maintenant la production de du nucléaire
à son niveau actuel donc je pense avoir
réussi grâce d'ailleurs au débat
parlementaire qui était d'excellente
qualité toute partie politique
confondues atterrir sur un bon équilibre
et en plus sur une dynamique qui me
permettait à la fois d'appliquer
l'accord de Paris sur le climat qui
prévoyait quand même la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables et
en même temps de sécuriser l'équipement
industriel du pays
merci bien monsieur Tanguy
le micro
bonjour madame la ministre
écoutez
les questions que je vais vous poser je
vais essayer de mieux comprendre le
certain nombre de conclusions à laquelle
vous avez abouti notamment j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une tension
permanente entre des intuitions assez
brillantes que vous avez vous avez parlé
du fait d'intégrer les océans dans les
discussions climatiques le rôle de la
pâte sur les femmes en particulier de se
réchauffement d'une part d'autre part
votre souci permanent et je crois enfin
ce n'est pas le juger mais en tout cas
je le perçois sincère de protéger les
classes populaires et les Français en
général les classes moyennes des impacts
de certaines décisions au dernier moment
un peu quand elles arrivent vraiment sur
la facture des des personnes et que vous
faites un cran d'arrêt vous mettez comme
vous vous mettez en travers de ces
décisions et d'un autre côté justement
le fait de ne pas de comment dire de ne
pas remettre en cause sur le fond
la pertinence de ces grands projets de
ces grandes décisions qui ont eu des
impacts sur les personnes donc j'essaie
de mieux comprendre sa tombe de décision
que vous avez prise et que vous avez
expliquer lors de cette audition
notamment la question des barrages des
concessions de barrage vous avez
expliqué que lors de votre arrivée au
ministère vous recevez une mise en
demeure de la de la Commission
européenne effectivement j'ai retrouvé
des positions de votre part très dure
contre cette mise en demeure mais
ensuite dans la loi vous faites voter
vous avez il y a plusieurs Verbatim dans
vos interventions en commission mais
aussi dans la presse vous dites avoir
trouvé une solution qui convient à la
Commission européenne et qui notamment
matia quand même l'ouverture de principe
des concessions à un mélange public
privé mais quand même avec des acteurs
privés or les dans les autres auditions
que nous avons faites
les différents dirigeants d'ef et
particuliers Monsieur Lévy a bien
indiqué qu'il y avait pas finalement de
prise de décision
efficaces sur ces concessions ce qui
fait que les concessions en fait le
l'exploitation la modernisation la
possibilité de mettre en exploitation de
meilleure façon ou de nouveaux gisements
hydroélectriques sont complètement
bloqués alors on nous a dit 10 voire 20
ans et justement de votre point de vue
est-ce que vous estimez que vous allez
trouver à bon accord ou au contraire que
c'est l'accord que vous allez trouver
n'a pas permis de solution puisque
depuis votre votre prise de fonction et
il y a pas de décision sur les
concessions il y a pas de travaux à part
les travaux de sécurité évidemment pour
que le l'outil industriel demeure mais
on a perdu beaucoup de temps et mon
autre question c'est que vous avez
défendu les EnR en particulier
l'hydroélectricité et justement ce que
vous estimez pas que sur ce côté
d'hydroélectricité en tant que mini vous
avez perdu une occasion de développer
les gisements français vous avez parlé
au tout début de votre audition
peut-être pouvez-vous le préciser que
l'hydroélectricité réglé ou régler j'ai
plus la mémoire le problème du stockage
alors il leur a potentiellement mais
aujourd'hui il est à son maximum de
stockage et sauf erreur vous n'avez pas
proposé ou enclenché de nouvelles
steppes de nouvelles possibilités de
stocker de l'énergie par
hydroélectricité alors est-ce que c'est
lié à ce problème des concessions ou
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
n'avez pas établi ou et j'en viens à
quelque chose qui que j'estime très
intéressant que vous avez dit est-ce que
vous n'avez pas eu d'informations sur la
possibilité de développer l'énergie
hydroélectrique puisque vous trouvez
tout un tas d'experts en carton qui vous
explique avec assurance que le
potentialités en France ont exploité à
leur maximum vont se rendre compte que
tout ça a été complètement bidon est-ce
qu'on vous a donné l'information qu'on
pouvait développer l'hydroélectricité ce
que vous ne l'aviez pas et justement je
trouve que c'est dommage parce que vous
avez abordé à toute fin et seulement par
une réponse à une question sur un
dossier particulier le rôle des
technocrates et la question que je me
pose depuis le début de ces auditions
c'est moi je suis pas là pour accuser
les gens des individus ça m'intéresse
pas en dehors de quelques cas qui sont
particulièrement odieux pendant leur
Odyssey mais mais est-ce que justement
dans la réflexion de cette commission
est-ce qu'avec toute l'expérience que
vous avez parce que c'est comme ça qui
est intéressant avec votre témoignages
aussi aujourd'hui de femmes d'État à la
fois d'une formation de technocrate et
je dis ça de manière positive et ensuite
de de prise de responsabilité à tous les
échelons de l'État est-ce que vous
estimez aussi depuis 30 ans il y a une
défaillance de l'information que les
technocrates doivent de manière
objective au décideurs politiques ou
alors un abandon vers les deux sont
possibles un abandon des décideurs d'un
certain nombre de pouvoir au
technocrates et un espèce de situation
finalement plus personne n'est
responsable de rien et on se retrouve
avec des situations
des dérives des dossiers qui sont jamais
clos des politiques qui ne vont pas au
bout de leurs idées
et donc une situation générale
d'irresponsabilité
il y a beaucoup de questions à votre
question
moi je pense que pour la dernière
question qu'est-ce que c'est que la
politique c'est avoir la capacité de
décider en étant éclairé bien évidemment
et en assumant ses responsabilités vous
voyez et quand il y a des ministres
faibles qui n'ont pas le rapport de
force politique qui n'ont pas le courage
de décider parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
outils pour décider effectivement ce
moment-là c'est la techno structure qui
prend le pouvoir qui fait d'ailleurs
souvent au mieux avec ses propres
convictions mais qui n'aura jamais le
compte à rendre vous voyez donc c'est ça
le problème le vrai problème et c'est ça
que j'ai observé si vous voulez quand je
vois tout ce qui a été mise en place pas
que par mois mais aussi au gré du débat
parlementaire et du travail considérable
qui a été fait au moment de la COP 21
pour la préparer pour équiper la France
dans la suite des choses et quand je
vois après que les choses s'écroule
c'est c'est voilà c'est désolant d'une
certaine façon parce pense que c'est du
gâchis d'un travail collectif
considérable voilà sur les barrages
comprend pas très bien votre question
parce que
ce que j'ai empêché c'est la mise en
concurrence comme ça s'est passé dans le
cas de la reine pour les énergies
nucléaire c'est-à-dire qu'on me sommet
de mettre en concurrence d'ouvrir à la
concurrence les concessions telles
qu'elles y compris avec des entreprises
venues de l'extérieur d'ailleurs il y a
plusieurs entreprises non françaises qui
avaient déjà témoigné de leur volonté de
venir sur le marché des concessions
il y a aucune raison qu'elle vienne sur
le marché des concessions
à partir du moment où les équipements
des barrages ont été payés par la France
et par nous tous dans le cadre de nos
factures d'énergie donc après il y a eu
j'ai dû trouver effectivement un
mécanisme pour calmer la commission sur
le thème et toute façon s'il y a des
les travaux s'il y a des marchés bien
évidemment il y aura des marchés de
travaux sur les barrages qui pourront
être ouvertes avec des accords privés
publics mais avec le privé qui reste
minoritaire je m'en souviens très bien
les privés dans la dispositif que j'ai
mis en place restez minoritaire et les
compagnies de production d'énergie
hydroélectriques restées en toute état
de cause majoritaire donc continuez à
garder le contrôle
et quant aux travaux je me souviens pas
avoir empêché des travaux ou après tout
les opérateurs énergéticiens si elle
voulait construire des des barrages
nouveaux il n'avait qu'à faire des
projets
aucune interdiction de produire de
l'hydroélectricité supplémentaire ou
d'aménager barrage ou d'augmenter leur
capacité de stockage
Tanguy voulait
pas été
merci pour préciser ma question en fait
l'audition thermique monsieur Livy nous
a été mis deux choses et que d'une part
la décision que vous avez prise n'a pas
soldé le problème des concessions et
qu'en fait eDF n'a toujours pas les
moyens sur la base du dispositif que
vous avez proposé deux dates de
reprendre en fait pleinement possession
ou non de ces barrages pareil pour ceux
qui sont dirigés par engie et que donc
si vous voulez le développement de
l'hydroélectricité on nous a dit depuis
20 ans et bloqué et la deuxième partie
de ma question c'était monsieur Levy
nous a indiqué avoir des potentialités
d'investissement et que comme c'est
bloqué à cause de cette histoire de
concession l'énergie hydroélectrique en
France n'est plus développée alors
qu'elle a de potes de scénopotentiels
depuis 10 ou 20 ans vous connaissez la
qualité et les intérêts technologiques
et environnemental de cette énergie donc
si vous voulez le fait que quand même le
PDG de DF informe cette commission que
depuis 20 ans ce secteur n'est pas n'est
pas développé par l'ensemble du
personnel politique
qui se charger de ce secteur pose quand
même problématique pour la souveraineté
énergétique puisque c'est l'énergie la
plus propre stockable est parfaitement
souveraine donc le fait que cette
énergie soit bloquée depuis 20 ans ou 10
ans vous comprenez que moi ça
m'interpelle énormément donc est-ce que
est-ce que vous on vous a oui ou non
proposé indiquer que c'était que cette
histoire de concession bloquer les
investissements dans l'hydroélectricité
est-ce que oui ou non vous a proposé
indiqué que il y avait une potentialité
d'investissement dans l'hydroélectricité
française de manière significative
notamment pour le stockage
une chose que je c'est un peu
contradictoire de leur propos de
Monsieur Lévy parce qu'il peut pas dire
à la fois qu'il y a pas d'investissement
depuis 20 ans et que là c'est à cause de
du refus de renouveler de privatiser les
concessions et qui a plus
d'investissement c'est quand même très
bizarre parce que
mais EDF n'est pas propriétaire de
toutes les de tous les barrages la
Compagnie nationale du Rhône
vous avez passé
la sécurité juridique
en tout cas ils m'ont jamais proposé une
autre solution donc c'est trop facile de
se dédouaner de leur responsabilités de
gestionnaire de d'équipements
et d'énergéticiens sur sur des décisions
qu'il me propose même pas de changer je
pense que ça aurait été pire honnêtement
donner à la concurrence il faut faire
venir des opérateurs étrangers sur nos
barrages je pense que là EDF
ne veut pas à la fois dire soutien ne
peut pas la fois soutenir cela et en
même temps se plaindre de la reine vous
voyez donc sinon les concessions ont été
vendues en effet à des prix inférieurs
peut-être à la valorisation des barrages
actuellement
il faut faire attention parce que mais
c'est un autre sujet parce que vous
voyez ce qui s'est passé sur l'arène est
en train de se faire sur les transports
c'est à dire que là on a libéralisé il y
a une libéralisation vous avez vu les
transports des trains qui viennent sur
les lignes les plus rentables parions
maintenant il y a des trains italiens
sauf que qui a payé les gars qui a payé
les rails
c'est la France qui a payé tout ça donc
vous voyez des opérateurs exactement
comme pour la reine qui viennent à des
prix inférieurs parce que du coup on
leur donne des concessions sur nos
équipements de transport public à un
prix inférieur à ce que coûterait le
prix du marché si te devait racheter ses
équipements là il les utilise puis quand
ils auront abusé le truc ils
disparaîtront ils sont même pas obligés
de faire les lignes secondaires faire
les petites gares moins rentables ils le
prennent que les lignes les plus
rentables par ils ont comme par hasard
alors que en utilisant mais les
infrastructures que la nation à payer on
recommence sous injonction de la
Commission européenne de libéraliser
uniquement les transports et même chose
sur garriconnexion il y a les gares les
gares qui rapportent il y a des bureaux
des commerces etc hier et connexion ça
ça rapporte du profit mais pourquoi
c'est pas reversé à l'organisation des
transports non on a séparé ce qui
rapporte de l'argent qui a été privatisé
ce qui en coûte et qui reste dans le
dans le secteur public c'est-à-dire les
transports de voyageurs donc faut être
vigilant
merci madame la ministre monsieur Dubois
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vais revenir sur deux
questions donc sur l'hydroélectricité
bien évidemment le renouvellement des
concessions et sur la reine dans mon
collègue rapporteur Antoine donc vous a
déjà posé la question vous avez répondu
en partie donc je vais commencer par par
la reine si vous voulez bien donc
effectivement je pose la question
suivante et on va le faire avec tous les
ministres donc qui ont participé donc à
ces choses là je pose la question à
Jean-Louis Borloo donc qui est le
porteur de la loi sur la reine donc sur
la loi normes
et Jean-Louis bordeau me répond bien que
la reine est pilotable
autant sur les volumes les senteurs de
départ que sur le prix
réévaluation du prix de la reine et vous
avez raison Madame la Ministre que ce
prix de la reine donc au départ à 40
euros le mégawatt était bien trop bas
en deux je pose la question donc
monsieur de la doucette de la creux sur
effectivement est-ce que ils ont avaient
remis un rapport sur ce prix de l'arène
et sur cette évaluation il me répond
bien que alors j'ai plus les dates mais
mon collègue le rapporteur a bien
précisé les dates que vous avez un
rapport qui vous est remis quand vous
êtes ministre et où il vous précise donc
qu'il est qu'il serait nécessaire de
prendre un décret pour réévaluer cette
arène sur le prix
je pose ensuite la question
au Premier ministre Emmanuel Valls sur
le pilotage de la reine
puisqu'il nous dit que lui
les ministres prenaient les orientations
et que il traitait les arbitrages en
tant que Premier ministre
et il me dit que sur le pilotage de la
reine
il a pas fait cet arbitrage là que ce
n'est pas venu jusque au cabinet du
Premier ministre
et qu'il fallait vous poser la question
donc sur ce décret
donc je vous suis sur le phénomène que
bloquer les prix de l'électricité
faire un prix régulier l'électricité
permettez déjà à l'ensemble des
consommateurs de payer une électricité
moins chère et de pas subir trop
d'évolution de prix et d'éviter aussi à
tous ces acheteurs
de la reine
sans être producteur de spéculer sur le
prix de l'électricité sauf que vous
aviez alors ça très bien vous avez fait
pris la première décision la deuxième
décision qui vous importez c'était et
par rapport pour être donc cohérent vous
aviez la possibilité vous l'avez dit
vous-même que c'était pas cohérent cette
arène vous aviez la possibilité de faire
qu'ils arrêtent de spéculer vous pouviez
baisser le volume par décret
depuis 2014 averti par la creux par
Monsieur Philippe de la doucette
vous n'avez pas pris ce décret
ensuite vous pouviez baisser vous
pouviez augmenter le prix le surévalué
en régulant de l'autre côté avec votre
tarif régulé plus vous auriez augmenté
le prix de la reine moins ils auraient
pu spéculer vous me l'accorderez
pourquoi vous avez pas prise décret
oui et je passe
et en 2010 donc ce que vous dites aussi
pendant quatre ans qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé moi j'arrive
en 2014 au ministère donc pendant quatre
ans si vous voulez les opérateurs sont
venus sur le marché vous êtes d'accord
ont signé des contrats donc quand
peut-être que je me souviens plus mais
peut-être que Monsieur Ladoux
c'est-à-dire augmenter la reine sauf que
il a pas beaucoup insisté monsieur
ladoussette pourquoi parce que les
opérateurs qui ont signé un contrat
Robert bah non nous on a signé le
contrat vous pouvez perdre du jour au
lendemain puis ils ont dû signer sur
plusieurs années je sais pas comment les
contrats étaient spécifiés mais les gars
qui sont venus sur ce créneau pour
spéculer ils ont ils sont pas bêtes ils
ont pas signé le contrat pour un an ils
ont signé le contrat donc une fois que
les contrats sont signés vous êtes
coincés alors est-ce qu'on pouvait
augmenter pour les nouveaux opérateurs
ça c'est possible mais est-ce qu'il y a
eu des nouveaux opérateurs en 2014 quand
j'arrive je ne sais pas
c'est possible mais voyez après les gens
ils disent le contrat vous pouvez pas
bouger
sur l'hydroélectricité c'est juste que
la creux attribue les volumes d'arène
une fois par an tous les ans
Michel il vous a dit quelque chose ça me
remontait pas moi les volumes
de mémoire je me souviens pas avoir
arbitré des volumes d'arène
et je pouvais mais voyez mais c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs ce que ça veut
dire aussi que je me permets de rebondir
du coup vous
n'arrive pas non plus dans les
arbitrages voyez
est-ce que c'est et Laurent Michel
est-ce qui vous a dit répondu là-dessus
parce que ça devait arriver à la
direction générale de l'énergie mais
aussi j'imagine que c'était un peu
interministériel
je sais pas si c'était moi seul qui
pouvait décider ça si j'avais su je peux
vous dire que j'aurais décidé parce que
ce que j'ai pu décider moi c'est le
bocage des prix c'est vous dire que
j'avais pas peur de changer la logique
des choses sur la reine je pense que
j'avais pas
vu passer le film et en tout cas on m'a
pas dit que j'avais le pouvoir de
bloquer qui avait des spéculateurs et
tout et tout ça ça je pense que je l'ai
pas vu
donc je suis intervenu comme j'ai pu en
bloquant le les tarifs pour parce que
j'avais entendu parler de la spéculation
je lui dis mais si j'augmente les tarifs
ils vont encore gagner plus d'argent ils
font ils vont encore plus spéculer et je
trouvais ça pas juste puisque je voyais
bien qu'ils achetaient à prix réduit
enfin en dessous du prix de production
EDF donc je me dis bah non c'est d'abord
à eux que ça allait profiter et pourtant
EDF insisté pour que j'augmente les prix
forcément parce qu'il voulait aussi un
grand jeu une différence
mais du coup le système est mais il faut
le changer il est pas trop tard pour le
changer je pense
alors juste avant de rebondir parce que
deux fois vous avez aussi émis la
critique de ces opérateurs alternatifs
qui
n'avait pas construit de moyens de
production
donc vous avez rien dit entre 2010 et
les opérateurs n'ont rien construit
c'était les quatre premières années de
la reine ils auraient dû commencer dès
le départ je suis assez d'accord mais
ils n'ont pas plus construit entre 2014
et 2017
vous avez un commentaire là-dessus
non j'ai pas de
sur les raisons pour lesquelles on n'a
pas vu qu'ils avaient pas construit
d'inspection c'est la nouvelle mode ça
risque pas d'être contrôlé facilement
c'est vrai
toute sa capacité d'hydroélectricité
c'est quand même général
les turbines avec les turbines des du
nucléaire les bras nous entendent aussi
je dis ça parce que moi j'étais pas pour
général électrique j'étais pour six
masse
j'étais pour une solution européenne
oui malheureusement on a la certitude
que par décret vous pouviez baisser le
volume et vous pouviez augmenter les
prix c'est dommage que cette décision
n'est pas été prise d'ailleurs de 2014 à
aujourd'hui parce que aujourd'hui on
peut encore
donc ma deuxième question elle va sur
elle revient sur l'hydroélectricité je
vais essayer de vous la poser plus de
façon plus pragmatique et plus pratique
puisque je suis député de la Corrèze de
la circonscription de Tulle et
Ussel donc
nous avons la vallée de la Dordogne sur
les renouvellements des concessions
depuis 2011 donc nous sommes en
infraction et je vous félicite sur le
phénomène que vous avez bien expliqué de
pas
céder à l'Europe sur ce renouvellement
de concession pour garder notre
entreprise EDF donc sur notre valet de
la Dordogne et ailleurs d'ailleurs en
France
le donc
sur les énergies renouvelables vous
faites une loi sur les énergies sur le
mixte sur le donc en 2015
le renouvelle les barrages sont
propriétés de l'État pour bien se
comprendre et le concessionnaire donc le
fermier c'est EDF à partir du moment où
ils ont pas le donc le renouvellement de
concession donc ils ont pas leurs droits
à faire mage
ils ne peuvent pas investir puisqu'ils
ont aucune garantie sur leur
investissement
donc ils avaient à ce moment là ils
avaient à ce moment là la possibilité
qui était connue je prends l'exemple de
la vallée de Dordogne notamment une
steppe donc sur redonna donc une station
de transfert d'énergie par pompage
pompage turbinage qui est l'équivalent
d'une tranche nucléaire
sur l'ensemble de la vallée ça
représente 5 gigawatt donc 5 tranches
nucléaires
EDF dit ce qui me paraît normal pour une
entreprise qui investit et c'est là où
c'est dommage vous aviez bien freiné
l'Europe il fallait leur donner la
possibilité et dans votre loi puisque
vous l'avez dit
l'hydroélectricité ou l'avez pas dit
mais moi je le précise 49% des énergies
renouvelables encore aujourd'hui et
complètement décarbonée
c'était important vous auriez pu dans la
loi
trouver un système juridique qui permet
à EDF alors je vous accorde un peu
d'être moins frileux et de faire ces
investissements
et il est dommage que dans votre loi
comme dans celle d'après d'ailleurs qui
ont suivi mais on est sur votre partie
de donc au ministère donc il a pas été
pris cette décision et ça aurait permis
se développements de l'hydroélectricité
et au niveau des énergies renouvelables
et peut-être aujourd'hui de pas être
donc en perte de souveraineté électrique
vraiment ce que je pense
honnêtement vous vous seriez pas trop de
DF on vous dit il y a des centrales
hydroélectriques à entretenir c'est
quand même le fleuron des énergies
renouvelables c'est un fleuron français
on est les meilleurs vous arrêtez vous
faites rien vous dire maintenant il faut
un décret maintenant il faut un arrêter
rien vous restez comme ça les bras
ballants alors Jean-Bernard Lévy c'est
une chance d'être patron d'une
entreprise comme ça d'être nommée patron
d'une entreprise comme ça et qui vient
pleurnicher parce qu'il a pas son arrêté
son décret pour entretenir les barrages
mérite pas d'être à la tête de DF que ce
que je voulais que je vous dise moi
librement tombe quand j'entends un
patron qui dit on a un fleuron dans les
énergies renouvelables mais on attend à
décrire un arrêté pour avoir le droit de
faire les travaux alors que je les
protège contre la mise sur le marché ils
auraient dû dire ah ben la ministre nous
protège contre la privatisation des
concessions
donc on est protégé on va entretenir et
on va investir sur nos barrages c'est
tout c'est pas des gens qui sont à la
hauteur ça qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise
ils viennent maintenant s'excuser
d'avoir rien fait excusez-moi de vous
demander pardon j'ai rien fait parce que
j'avais pas mon décret mon arrêté le
gars qu'on protège parce que je me bats
contre la Commission européenne pour pas
qu'il a mis sur le marché des
concessions qui auraient fait toutes
écrouler parce que on aurait eu pareil
des spéculateurs parce que ça a de la
valeur un barrage qu'est-ce que j'avais
vu moi je voyais déjà le long des
opérateurs énergéticiens les autres pays
européens venir sur le marché ça a de la
valeur un barrage c'est un magnifique
c'est une magnifique réalisation donc il
y aurait eu aussi une spéculation les
gens seraient venus aurai acheté ça à
rentrer dans leur bilan et moi j'ai pas
accepté ça
et derrière vous avez un patron d'EDF
qui fait pas les investissements
c'est pas c'est pas sérieux c'est pas
sérieux
j'aurais dû donner l'ordre de faire les
investissements et comme j'étais déjà 15
heures par jour au travail je pouvais
pas en plus contrôler ce que vous avez
le patron de DF pour entretenir ses
barrages vous savez c'est
merci Madame la Ministre madame lernos
oui merci
je suis désolé j'ai fait des
allers-retours sur les retraites et sur
la commission des affaires économiques
mais j'ai eu les retours des questions
qui ont été posées les réponses que vous
avez données je voulais revenir avec
vous sur l'objectif des 50% à horizon
2025 et surtout parce que notre
commission d'enquête il s'agit de la
sécurité et la souveraineté énergétique
de la France vous avez évoqué plutôt
dans votre audition la dangerosité
quelque part de mettre je sais pas
exactement le terme que vous avez
utilisé mais en tout cas de miser sur le
tout nucléaire sur la filière du
nucléaire et vous avez également indiqué
que les investissements vous en avez
parlé lors sur les MOX sur diverses pans
du nucléaire avait empêché les
investissements français dans les
énergies renouvelables c'est donc est-ce
que
le fait d'avoir que l'État français a
tout misé sur le nucléaire pour sa
stratégie énergétique est-ce que ça a
opéré les investissements dans les
énergies renouvelables malgré les
différents chantiers que vous avez
énumérés que vous avez lancé quand vous
étiez ministre de l'écologie d'ailleurs
c'est les mêmes propos qu'Emmanuel
Macron reprend au début de son précédent
quinquennat une question plus précise
sur notamment la filière photovoltaïque
et le dumping chinois qui a été opéré il
me semble que sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande Bruxelles a tenu face
aux Chinois justement pour mettre des
mesures en place pour protéger la
filière photovoltaïque en Europe et que
c'est 2000 début 2018 que cela a été
abandonné et qu'aujourd'hui on a plus de
filière d'énergie renouvelables à
proprement parler en tout cas on l'a
fortement abîmé en laissant place au
marché chinois et peut-être que vous
avez de première main puisque c'était
aussi là où vous étiez en exercice il y
a une bataille qui a été menée à
Bruxelles sur les énergies renouvelables
notamment face au dumping chinois c'est
en termes de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique une question sur la
thermocensibilité madame la ministre
comme ça
2018 moi je suis plus responsabilité
donc je sais pas trop ce qui s'est passé
au niveau européen ce qui est ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'on n'a pas de filière en
Europe digne de ce nom
sur le l'ensemble des énergies
renouvelables notamment la fabrication
du des panneaux photovoltaïques et ce
qu'on comprend pas c'est pourquoi il y a
pas une alliance au niveau européen pour
construire une filière européenne dans
ce domaine-là une des réponses on vient
de la voir par rapport aux éléments
qu'on vient d'évoquer sur le sur la
libéralisation de tous les marchés on a
une Europe qui encourage les pays
européens à se faire concurrence les uns
contre les autres et pendant ce temps-là
aux États-Unis d'Amérique ils font bloc
et les États-Unis d'Amérique on dit pas
un état de se faire concurrence au
voisin donc c'est absolument crucial que
dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique et c'est ce que j'ai plaidé
moi quand je me suis libéralisation des
concessions c'est qu'il est des
possibilités d'accord et
d'investissement des états et de
stratégie d'union entre les différents
pays européens au lieu de les forcer de
se faire concurrence des uns contre les
autres c'est ça qui ne va pas dans la
transition énergétique et écologique
c'est-à-dire il y a pas eu de
revisiter les concepts de libre marché
par rapport aux exigences de la
transition énergétique et de
l'obligation d'appliquer l'accord de
Paris sur le climat alors que c'est là
qu'il faut inventer justement des
dérogations pour être plus fort
ça c'est la première chose il est pas
trop tard je pense ça se désenjeux
vraiment à prendre à bras le corps
maintenant sur la question de est-ce que
le tout nucléaire a empêché les
investissements non je ne crois pas que
le tout nucléaire est empêché les
investissements dans le renouvelable je
pense qu'on est passé à côté des
opportunités qu'on avait en France quand
il y a eu la décision du tout nucléaire
parce que c'est le tout nucléaire qu'il
a emporté ça permet à la fois une
performance exceptionnelle en disant des
constructions de réacteur nucléaire
comme nulle part ailleurs dans le monde
mais parallèlement ça limite
complètement de côté et dans le mépris
parce qu'il faut aller voir les discours
des ingénieurs à ce moment-là où le
solaire l'éolien c'était pour les pour
les babas cool quoi et donc les
ingénieurs au sein même de DF qui
s'occupait de ces secteurs étaient
considérés de façon complètement
marginale la noblesse du métier
d'énergéticien c'était le nucléaire donc
ça c'est positif tant mieux pour le
nucléaire
mais le reste était considéré comme
secondaire comme des faux ingénieurs
comme ceci comme cela alors que on avait
aussi des outils de de recherche et de
réalisation dans les secteurs des
énergies renouvelables c'est ça qui est
dommage on avait le solaire à Font-Romeu
on a inventé les éoliennes je disais
dans les laboratoires de Poitiers donc
on avait aussi la compétence on a eu la
première voiture électrique en France
donc c'est pas normal qu'il y a pas eu
un test la français si on avait soutenu
cette filière comme moi j'ai essayé de
le faire et malheureusement j'ai même
pas eu le soutien du ministère d'énergie
à l'époque quand je crée la mia
électrique chez eolièse parce que je
découvre qu'il y a ce potentiel et ses
brevets français qui sont développés et
donc on est passé à côté d'un potentiel
mais bon c'est le passé je pense que et
c'est pour ça que la France doit se
faire confiance dans son dans sa
capacité à développer le renouvelable
en fait en bref ma question en creux
c'est de dire quand vous mettez dans la
loi
l'objectif des 50% à horizon 2025 est-ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'au sein de
l'État où est-ce qu'il y a eu des
lobbies ou des vents contraires pour
faire en sorte que cet objectif ne soit
pas réalisé vous l'avez évoqué ça
voulait dire une montée en puissance ça
ne voulait pas forcément fermer des
réacteurs dire fermer des réacteurs mais
ça voulait dire diminuer notre
consommation énergétique et surtout
faire monter en puissance les énergies
renouvelables hors force est de
constater que ça n'a pas été le cas donc
est-ce que pour comprendre pourquoi cet
objectif n'a pas été réalisé et que au
final votre successeur de plusieurs
successeurs plus tard Nicolas Hulot a
été obligé de dire que ça serait pas
horizon 2025 mais 2035 qu'aujourd'hui
c'est remis en cause dans la loi sur
l'accélération sur le nucléaire qui a
été votée au Sénat est-ce que pour vous
cet objectif dans une planification
stable vous l'avez dit vous aviez une
stratégie claire qui avait été adoptée
avant la COP pour que la France au nord
ces engagements est-ce que cette
stratégie était faisable d'un point de
vue technique politique et est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que tout le monde
n'était pas raccord et qu'au sein même
de l'État il y avait des vents
contraires qui ont fait et qui ont
empêché qu'on ne puisse réaliser à
horizon 2025 2030 cet objectif des 50%
. j'ai pas senti de lobby à ce point
pronucléaire qui empêchait les énergies
renouvelables de toute façon c'est pas
ça qui m'aurait arrêté donc les outils
que je mets en place que j'ai développé
tout à l'heure que ce soit les appels
d'offres dans les énergies renouvelables
que ce soit la finance vers que ce soit
le crédit d'impôt que ce soit les
territoires énergies positifs je mets en
place un dispositif complet qui va de
l'industrie aux particuliers pour que
tout le monde tire dans la même
direction et d'ailleurs sauf erreur de
ma part quand je quitte le ministère on
est monté en puissance sur les
renouvelables puisqu'on a l'équivalent
de production sauf erreur de ma part de
six réacteurs nucléaires en énergie
renouvelable ma conviction profonde
c'est que si cette dynamique s'était
prolongée
là on aurait peut-être même aujourd'hui
des filières dans le bâtiment et dans
les énergies renouvelables parmi les
premières d'Europe sur ce secteur là
puisque nous sommes le pays qui le
premier met en place sa stratégie black
carbone avec la loi de doute 2015 qui
met en place les outils qui met en place
et financement donc si ça n'avait pas
été stoppé net en 2017 je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on serait monté en
puissance et pas au dépend du nucléaire
pourquoi pas aux dépenses du nucléaire
parce que le nucléaire de toute façon
même si on reste au même niveau de
production a besoin de d'investissement
de sécurité sur ces centrales donc
l'idée c'était pas de continuer
d'augmenter en puissance le nucléaire
c'était déjà de sécuriser les 63,2
gigawatts parce que pour les sécuriser
il faut des investissements dans la
sécurité aujourd'hui dans la sûreté des
centrales donc de toute façon le
nucléaire avait besoin de moyens donc
c'était pas la peine
pour tomber de l'autre côté du cheval et
aller du côté des pros nucléaires
d'imaginer la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs ça sera impossible à
construction de vous dire je vais vous
dire le fond de ma pensée
à construire de nouveau réacteurs vous
tous vous les mettez où dans quel
territoire vous voyez aujourd'hui une
commune ou un département accepté des
réacteurs ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
construire de nouveau réacteurs sur les
emprises actuelles des centrales c'est
pas pareil mais ce que les Français ont
compris c'est qu'on allait faire des
réacteurs mais où vous procède preneur
vous n'envoi circonscriptions d'un
réacteur nucléaire
mais dans 40 ans mais il faut il faut 20
ans pour le construire
non c'est pas ça mais je veux dire
l'impact en termes d'emploi et d'énergie
sur un territoire c'est peut-être plus
fortement en matière d'économie
d'énergie de performance des bâtiments
d'énergie renouvelables et de toute
façon il faut investir sur les réacteurs
actuels j'ai dit tout à l'heure il y a
des problèmes de corrosion il y a
beaucoup de problèmes d'entretien donc
déjà investir pour que les réacteurs
actuels restent actifs c'est déjà un
objectif ambitieux donc il m'a inventé
ou annoncer de nouveaux réacteurs alors
c'est peut-être pour consolider la
filière que c'est fait parce que la
parole politique aussi elle consolide
elle consolide elle renforce la
confiance de la filière en elle-même
mais l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte que tous les aujourd'hui
au moment où on en parle aujourd'hui
de ma part il y a 13 réacteurs à l'arrêt
donc vous allez construire de nouveaux
réacteurs avec un a très à redémarrer
s'ils sont correctement entretenus non
donc c'est une question aussi de mon
sens à un moment et de et d'allocation
optimale des ressources publiques
dans le prolongement puisque beaucoup de
personnes qu'on a auditionnées nous ont
dit que c'était à cause du des
investissements dans la filière du
nucléaire que
l'état de la filière nucléaire en France
n'arrivait pas à rouvrir par exemple un
EPS comme Flamanville ça a été certain
des auditionnés qui ont pu affirmer ça
au gré des auditions
personnellement j'ai eu plus
l'impression qu'il y a eu des
divergences aussi au sein de la filière
vous avez évoqué le fait de conditionner
la fermeture de Fessenheim notamment en
préservant les emplois en créant et vous
avez parlé de Tesla mais vous avez aussi
parlé de devenir champion puisque il y a
des réacteurs vieillissants dans tous
les pays qui en ont installé dans les
mêmes années que la France et donc de
créer une filière qui serait là aussi et
dont on aurait besoin des compétences
donc la première question est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que c'est un
problème d'investissement dans le
nucléaire français qui fait que
nucléaire ne marche pas aujourd'hui ou
marche moins bien en France ou pas donc
ça c'est la
question essentielle c'est celle-ci
c'est de dire est-ce que c'est à cause
puisque c'est ça qui est remis en cause
est-ce que c'est un accord factice entre
les socialistes et les écologistes qu'on
fait qu'on a moins baissé dans le
nucléaire ou dans les faits est-ce que
on n'a pas mis en place les bonnes
filières notamment dans la
déconstruction ou la sécurisation des
centrales dont on a besoin et dont on va
avoir besoin et sur lequel on aurait pu
créer une filière dans le nucléaire
pourvoyeuse d'emploi
la question c'est pourquoi le retard de
Flamanville alors que parallèlement EDF
investissait sur une clip point
ils ont peut-être pas été
particulièrement judicieux
oui parce qu'on investissait vers les
syndicats d'EDF avait beaucoup réagi à
ce moment-là je regarde les villes il
était très acharné sur une clip point
il voulait absolument réaliser une
clipoint y compris d'ailleurs la France
on a payé une partie quand même et nos
opérateurs et nos techniciens nos
ingénieurs sont aussi allés à une clip
point donc je pense qu'il imaginait
qu'en réalisant une clépoid avant
flamment ville ça allait faire pouvoir
permettre de de conquérir des marchés à
l'international c'était un point de vue
moi j'ai toujours eu un doute sur ce sur
ce point de vue enfin il était tellement
acharné sur une clipping il était pas
trop d'EDF et plusieurs fois j'ai posé
la question mais est-ce qu'il faut mieux
pas finir flamme en ville quand même
avant
et je pense que les choses étaient déjà
engagées mais ça me paraissait quand
même bizarre d'aller financer une clé
point qui redémarrer avant Flamanville
alors qu'il a commencé après et de
perdre du potentiel de compétences alors
que Flamanville ne démarrait pas ça
c'est ça c'est une vraie question de la
location optimale des ressources au sein
d'une entreprise
publique pratiquement
moi je vais je pardon je suis
auditionnée à 19h parce qu'ils ont vu
que j'étais là alors maintenant le Sénat
m'a convoqué sur la rénovation
énergétique à 19h faut que je sois au
Sénat
juste pour avoir du coup votre réponse
pendant l'exercice de votre mandat en
tant que ministre vous n'avez pas eu
l'impression qu'on a désinvestis dans le
nucléaire mais plutôt que le choix qui a
été fait là où les investissements ont
été mis
on vous parlait d'une plutôt que de se
focaliser sur Flamanville on a eu aussi
des auditions on disait est-ce qu'il
fallait à l'exportation ce qui était une
volonté d'un certain nombre de figures
de la filière nucléaire et donc on a
fait le choix d'allouer les moyens sur
le nucléaire plutôt à l'exportation
plutôt que de les focaliser sur la
filière interne à savoir réussir flamand
ville et réussir une de créer une vraie
filière de démantèlement des centrales
c'est ça
c'était les choix internes à
l'entreprise
de l'énergie interviens pas d'un
interfère pas sur toutes les choix
stratégiques internes à l'entreprise EDF
on discute on posait des quiches poser
des questions je voyais bien qui est pas
forcément une seule
une seule vérité mais après c'est du
choix stratégiques de l'entreprise
c'est la responsabilité
non j'avais une dernière question sur
les déchets mais il me semble que vous
avez déjà répondu partiellement à cette
question de la raison pour laquelle vous
étiez opposé notamment à l'enfouissement
des déchets en profondeur et de manière
irréversible il me semble que vous avez
utilisé tous vos pouvoirs à l'époque
pour faire en sorte que la réversibilité
était indiquée
monsieur Tanguy succinctement
oui
la deuxième question que je voulais vous
poser tout à l'heure c'était vous avez à
de nombreuses reprises utilisées le mot
croyance et ma maman justement en
parlant des déchets vous avez parlé même
que c'était viscéral je crois ou une
autre métaphore gastrique
le
moi ce qui m'inquiète si vous fasse qui
me pose question
oui mais le cœur vous avez parlé de
l'Egypte il pensait que l'esprit était
dans le coeur mais enfin le la science a
montré qu'ils avaient tort sur ce point
le le
c'est vraiment un certain nombre de
parfois je me demande si quand même
est-ce que quelques années après vous
vous dites pas que vous êtes trompé sur
les possibilités de certaines
technologies bon par exemple vous avez
quand même vendu la route solaire
on peut quand même pas me dire dans
l'ordre d'un projet qui s'est quand même
avéré comme un échec technologique
majeur pour alors certes c'est un
prototype mais même encore aujourd'hui
quand vous reprenez encore comme exemple
vous parlez aujourd'hui à l'échelle du
monde il y a 10-15% de renouvelables 10%
nucléaire certes madame mais vous êtes
aussi en accord vous dites en même temps
que le la transition climatique est un
échec donc de toute évidence la
progression des renouvelables
intermittentes par rapport au nucléaire
ne permet pas la transition climatique
que l'on aimerait tous voir réussi et
vous voyez bien vous arrivez vous avez
connu deux périodes vous avez connu la
période du tout nucléaire que vous avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises il y avait
aucun problème d'approvisionnement
électrique en France on peut critiquer
d'autres choses les déchets tout ça mais
le système fonctionnait il y avait pas
de crise on parlait pas de faire des
économies d'électricité l'hiver bon et
depuis que le technologies
intermittentes sont arrivées dans le mix
français je parle pas de d'autres pays
je parle pas des pays en voie de
développement je parle de la France plus
rien ne fonctionne le système est
perturbé déséquilibré les financements
ne vont pas où il faut on ne sait plus
gérer la pointe on est dépendant de nos
concurrents donc est-ce qu'il y a comme
et vous continuez je vous ai pas à dire
en plus et vous continuez à défendre
cette technologie et vous avez parlé par
exemple vous avez dit oui les énergies
marines aujourd'hui Madame Royale
objectivement les énergies marines
personne ne mise à kopeck dessus parce
que si vous voulez le les métaux et la
mer ça va pas très bien ensemble donc
est-ce que je vous ai pas interrompu à
la merde d'une manière générale voilà
est-ce que quand même avec votre
expérience j'ai presque oui mais
j'essaie de quand même de dire quelque
chose mais est-ce qu'il y a une autre
expérience quand même sincèrement
aujourd'hui vous continuerez à dire
qu'on peut qu'on peut assurer une
transition climatique avec 50% nucléaire
et 50% de renouvelables dont 35%
d'intermittentes est-ce qu'aujourd'hui à
l'expérience de ce qui s'est passé en
Allemagne vous avez parlé de l'Espagne
par rapport à la France est-ce que vous
estimez que c'est toujours techniquement
possible ou est-ce que soit vous êtes
peut-être trompé ou alors vous a donné
une mauvaise information
planète
si je peux me permettre parce que vous
nous dites il y avait le nucléaire et
pas de problème tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes mais monsieur
l'irréacteur maintenant ils ont 40 ans
est-ce que vous connaissez la durée de
vie moyenne aujourd'hui des réacteurs
français puisque vous connaissez bien
l'énergie nucléaire
quel est aujourd'hui la durée de vie
moyenne des réacteurs français
non mais ils ont été construits pour 40
ans il fait fermer au bout de 40 ans
est-ce qu'ils ont fermé est-ce qu'ils
ont fermé
alors quelle est la durée de vie moyenne
des réacteurs français actuellement
voilà donc normalement si on suivait ce
qui est attendez je finis je vous ai
écouté je vous ai écouté si c'est
Monsieur permettez vous nous dites le
nucléaire ça suffisait ça résout tous
les problèmes sauf que si on suivait ce
qu'on dit les ingénieurs qui ont
construit ces centrales nucléaires il y
a 40 ans aujourd'hui toutes les
centrales devraient fermer est-ce que
c'est le cas non donc si donc donc
aujourd'hui on a besoin de réinvestir
dans ces centrales pour les sécuriser
pour qu'elle continue à produire de
l'énergie ça coûte pas rien ça c'est
beaucoup
c'est énormément d'investissement et le
nouveau nucléaire coûte deux fois plus
cher que l'ancien nucléaire et que votre
commission le vérifiera écoute écoute en
tout cas beaucoup plus cher que les
énergies renouvelables et n'assurent pas
à l'indépendance énergétique de la
France parce que nous n'avons pas de
plutonium donc nous n'avons pas
d'uranium nous donc nous n'avons pas de
de le
combustible des centrales nous ne
produisons pas donc nous devons la
porter d'accord là-dessus
bien effectivement lorsque nous
arriverons peut-être à faire des progrès
technologiques donc la question c'est
pas comme vous faites de poser les
énergies les unes aux autres c'est de
construire un modèle énergétique ou le
nucléaire est complété par le
renouvelable et par les économies
d'énergie c'est ce qui est fait donc
c'est pas la peine de tomber d'une
idéologie dans une autre vous êtes dans
l'idéologie du tout nucléaire vous
pensez qu'il y a un âge d'or et qu'il
faudrait poursuivre cet âge d'or mais
physiquement
scientifiquement de toute façon ces
centrales ces réacteurs ils ont besoin
d'un investissement considérable pour
être remise à niveau donc si on peut
produire de l'énergie qui assure
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
par rapport aux énergies renouvelables
et qui en plus ne provoquent pas de gaz
à effet de serre et bien ce serait pas
raisonnable de ne pas le faire et donc
la complémentarité entre les deux c'est
la bonne solution
bien merci beaucoup madame la ministre
de vous être rendu disponible pour notre
commission d'enquête pour les réponses
que vous avez apportées à nos nombreuses
questions et pour les éclairages que
cela apporte à notre commission
également sur la façon dont un certain
nombre de décisions ont pu être prises
sous votre autorité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée je vous donne rendez-vous
tout à l'heure au membre de la
commission d'enquête